Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 147. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu einer Ausgabe, die uns mal sehr weit nach draußen führen wird. Danach sieht es zumindest aus. Und genauer geht es darum, mal ein wenig in den Kosmos und in die unendlichen Weiten einzutauchen. Ja, und da lässt sich eigentlich gar nicht mehr ankündigen, außer noch dem Gast dieser Sendung, der da kundig Auskunft geben möchte. Ich begrüße Robert Helling. Hallo, Robert.
Hallo.
Willkommen bei Chaosradio Express. Und ja, jetzt setzen wir hier und wollen uns mal direkt hier sozusagen von Ground-Level 0 in die Unendlichkeit begeben. Aber bevor wir das vielleicht tun, sollten wir vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen ausholen. Und mich wird natürlich auch erstmal interessieren, was so dein Hintergrund in dieser ganzen Geschichte eigentlich ist.
Also ich bin Physiker. Ich habe das studiert und habe das Glück, das immer noch tun zu können. Ich bin an der Uni in München als Wissenschaftler angestellt. LMU.
Ah ja, richtig. LMU heißt das, Entschuldigung.
Ludwig Maximilianz-Universität.
Was ist das da so für ein Bereich?
Also ich bin theoretischer Physiker und mein Spezialgebiet ist String-Theorie, was eigentlich das Kleinste ist, was man überhaupt haben kann.
Zumindest nach dem aktuellen Weltbild.
Ja, beziehungsweise wenn sich das Weltbild verschiebt, bleiben wir dran.
Genau, ihr kümmert euch ja sozusagen um das kleinste Detail.
Genau.
Aber nicht nur. Was umfasst denn das so, theoretische Physik? Wie muss man sich denn das vorstellen? Sind das die Leute, die sich nicht trauen, den Hammer selbst nie anzunehmen, sondern die lieber drüber reden?
Ja, also wir versuchen halt, Physik zu machen, indem man über Dinge nachdenkt und mehr als, dass man ins Labor geht und Experimente macht. Aber theoretische Physik ist alles. Wir reden über alles mit. Theoretische Physik sind halt Elementarteilchen oder eben der Kosmos. Aber das kann auch der Verkehrsstau auf der Autobahn sein.
Der Verkehrsstau auf der Autobahn, was hat denn das mit theoretischer Physik zu tun?
Weil die einzelnen Autos, wenn man die zusammen nimmt und viele Autos zusammen anguckt, verhalten die sich im Prinzip so wie die Moleküle in so einem Gas zum Beispiel. Und deswegen kann man den Verkehrsstau auf der Autobahn genauso modellieren wie so ein Gas. Und die Gleichungen sind da sehr ähnlich. Oder Finanzderivate verhalten sich, wenn sie das denn tatsächlich mal tun, nach den gleichen Gleichungen wie die Quantenmechanik.
Also auch wie ein Gas oder was?
Nein, mehr wie ein quantenmechanisches Teilchen, was durch die Gegend wandert.
Also nicht so richtig vorhersagbar.
Nicht so richtig vorhersagbar, genau. Und wenn es darum, ganz konkret, wenn es darum geht, von so einem modernen Finanzprodukt, von so einem Derivat, den Preis auszurechnen, tut man das mit einer Gleichung, die die gleiche Gleichung ist wie die Schrödinger Gleichung, die halt die quantenmechanische Bewegung eines Teilchens beschreibt. Insofern machen wir alles. Wir denken über alles nach.
Das heißt, in diesem ganzen Finanzbusiness geht es eigentlich um tote Katzen?
Im Prinzip ja. Und die Leute, die da schuld sind, also von denen, die da in London oder New York sitzen und vielleicht auch mit schuld in der Finanzkrise sind, sind ganz viele ehemalige theoretische Physiker.
Nein.
Doch.
Ach, ihr seid schuld?
Ja, wir sind schuld. Wir heißen die Quants.
Ach echt, innerhalb der Finanzwelt. Ja.
Die können halt diese Modelle beschreiben, die dann halt auf Computern laufen, womit man halt sich überlegt, was ist es wert, dass sich am 31.12. eine IBM-Aktie zu dem und dem Preis verkaufen kann.
Sind das jetzt die Leute, die man besser nicht hätte zuhören sollen?
Nein, im Prinzip glauben wir schon, dass wir relativ viel verstehen, aber so ein Modell ist halt nie perfekt.
Wir wissen, dass wir nichts wissen. Ja, genau.
Aber wir reden trotzdem gern über alles.
Und was hat dich jetzt selbst da bewogen, sich da in diese Richtung hinzuentwickeln?
Also das hat mich schon immer interessiert. Also als Kind äußerte sich das dadurch, dass ich Astronaut werden wollte. Ich wollte nicht Lokführer werden, ich wollte Astronaut werden. Und das habe ich im Prinzip gemacht, nur dass ich halt irgendwie zu unproktisch bin, um in so ein Raumschiff zu schreien. Also das wusste ich schon immer, irgendwie Weltraum und so was mich interessiert.
Unendliche Weiten.
Unendliche Weiten, genau.
Da hast du auch mal schön Star Trek geguckt.
Natürlich habe ich immer schön Star Trek geguckt und auch das ganz toll gefunden. Ich hatte einen Freund im Kindergarten, da hatte er einen Pubcomputer.
Ein Pubcomputer?
Ein Pubcomputer. Das war so eine Tastatur und so ein Monitor aus Puppe in Originalgröße. Und das war ein Superspielzeug. Der hatte auch eine Taste. Der hatte zwei Tasten, da stand CTRL drauf. Und da waren wir ganz sicher, wenn man da drauf drückt, redet man mit der Zentrale.
Das ist eine schöne Deutung. Genau. Zentrale, Zentrale bitte kommen.
Ja, genau, ganz genau so.
Ah, es gibt mehrere Zentralen, wir müssen uns mit Zentrale A verbinden. Oder Zentrale C. Okay, und dann bist du es auch geworden, das heißt, du hast dich dann sozusagen direkt an Studium rumgefragt, wo kommt man in den Weltall am nächsten, und dann meinten die Physik.
Ja, das habe ich schon in der Schule irgendwie gemerkt. Das war nicht, ob ich Mathematik oder Physik studieren soll, aber Mathematik war ich in der Schule zu übersättigt von. Und hier gehört es sich ja irgendwie ein abgebrochenes Informatikstudium anzuführen. Bei mir hat das einen Tag gedauert, dann war ich da wieder aus dem Gehörsaal raus. Echt?
Du warst ja schneller raus als ich.
Nein, dann wüsste ich, Physik ist mein Ding. Und seitdem mache ich das auch.
Und jetzt bist du sozusagen da auch voll im Lehrbetrieb, oder ist das auch schon eher ein Forschungsbereich?
Also was, die arbeitet man denn da? Also ganz konkret wäre ich bezahlt dafür, dass ich einen Studiengang managere. Also es gibt ja diese neuen Bologna reformierten Studiengänge. Und da haben wir einen Studiengang, einen Masterstudiengang an der LMU in Theoretischer Physik zusammen mit der Mathematik. Und für die bin ich verantwortlich. Das ist mein Broterwerb und dann halte ich auch Vorlesungen ab und zu. Und wenn ich dann noch Zeit habe, forsche ich auch selber noch.
Wird das von einem erwartet, dass man da forscht?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also da gibt es keinen festen Prozentsatz, aber natürlich wird das...
Aber du erwartest das auch von dir selbst?
Ich erwarte das auch von mir selbst.
Ja, du hast ja zu diesem ganzen Universums-Kontext auch einen Kongressvortrag gehalten auf dem letzten 26C3. So bin ich auch so ein bisschen auf die Idee gekommen, das Thema nochmal aufzugreifen. Nicht weil ich der Meinung war, dass das nicht aussagefähig gewesen wäre, sondern weil ich irgendwie die ganze Zeit das Gefühl hatte, da müsste man ja eigentlich nochmal ein bisschen genauer drüber reden und mal nachhaken. Ich erinnere mich natürlich jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau, in welchem Moment mir dann irgendwie so dieser Ding kam. Aber es ist natürlich auch eine mega komplexe Materie. Aber vielleicht ist es das ja auch nicht. Also die Intention jetzt heute ist, so ein bisschen mal nachzuvollziehen, was man denn eigentlich so weiß über unser Dasein und damit natürlich im weiteren Sinne auch so das Universum, Kosmos, was man mal sagen will, was für ein Wort verwendest du denn eigentlich so für das Ganze?
Ich sage Universum.
Das ist mögliche. Gibt es da nur eins?
Oh, das ist gleich eine der Fragen, über die ich dachte, die reden wir jetzt zum Schluss.
Das können wir auch am Schluss dann noch machen. Okay, das ist schon mal eine der Fragen.
Ich schreibe mir das mal auf meinen Zettel, dass wir das nicht vergessen.
Ja, das Multiversum.
Genau, genau, genau.
Na ja, gut, also ein Verständnis von der Welt zu bekommen, das treibt natürlich die Menschheit schon immer an. Da kann man jetzt wahrscheinlich beliebig weit zurückgehen, aber so in die Sterne gucken, das gehörte auf jeden Fall immer schon zu den bevorzugten Sportarten bei der anderen Kultur, das weiß ich. Die Ägypter haben da sicherlich einige Zeit mit verbracht. Alle. Die Mayas und so weiter, alle wahrscheinlich.
Die wissen, wann man seinen Weizen aufs Feld bringt.
Genau. Dabei gab es aber noch kein Internet und so. Da konnte man sich ja eigentlich auch nicht so richtig beschäftigen. Was soll man dann sonst anderes machen, als die ganze Nacht auf dem Feld zu sitzen und in den Sterne zu klotzen? Aber wann hat denn das so angefangen, dass so der Menschheit gewahr wurde, was eigentlich wirklich abgeht? Galilie oder was? Oder war das noch nicht mal?
Also Galilie hat natürlich wichtige Sachen rausgefunden. Darüber, wer denn im Zentrum des Universums steht. Also der hat ja dafür gesorgt, dass die Erde da weggerückt worden ist und die Sonne da hin gerückt worden ist.
Auch wenn das nicht die ganze Antwort war, aber...
Das ist schon ein guter Schritt, jedenfalls. Und dann ist es halt in großen Schritten weitergegangen. Der nächste Name, der da fallen muss, ist irgendwie Kepler. Der gemerkt oder realisiert hat, was auch daher kam, dass man irgendwie angefangen hat, richtig numerische Messungen zu machen. Und das passte mit diesem Bild nicht mehr, dass die Planeten auf Kreisbahnen um die Sonne laufen. Das funktioniert relativ gut, aber es sind halt doch keine Kreise. Kepler hat festgestellt, dass das Ellipsen sind. Also etwas deformierte Kreise.
Aber dass die überhaupt schon mal so rumwandern, das hatte man schon so verstanden.
Dass da irgendwas wandert, sieht man eben, wenn man in den Himmel guckt.
Na klar. Man muss ja auch schon relativ lange hingucken, bei so manchen Planeten. Der Pluto ist irgendwie, seitdem man ihn das erst mal als Planeten bezeichnet hat, bis er dann keiner mehr sein durfte, ist er glaube ich noch nicht einmal rum.
Ich glaube halb. Halb rum. Aber den hat man ja erst im frühen 20. Jahrhundert überhaupt entdeckt. Also den kann man halt nur auf Foto-Platten sehen. Deswegen sind immer diese Horoskope, wo irgendwie Pluto eine wichtige Rolle steht, aber die sich darauf berufen, dass sie irgendwie Jahrhunderte altes Wissen verbraten, immer besonders interessant.
Interessanter Aspekt. Ich denke, mit Astrologie wirst du es nicht so haben. Da kommt man wahrscheinlich schnell von ab, wenn man sich mit theoretischer Physik beschäftigt. Kepler hat sozusagen die Sachen mit den Ellipsen rausgefunden. Der hat also etwas genauer hingeschaut.
Und dann ist...
Ist denn daraus schon irgendeine andere Erkenntnis zu leiten?
Das ist der nächste Schritt. Da kommt der Mann in England mit den Äpfeln, Newton, Herr Newton, ins Geschäft. Der irgendwie gerade für die theoretische Physik ein unheimlich wichtiger war. Der vieles gemacht hat, aber der hat eben... Also eines der Dinge, die er gemacht hat, ist festzustellen, dass man eben, wenn man dieses Newtonische Gravitationsgesetz hernimmt, dass Dinge Massen angezogen werden und dass die Kraft umgekehrt proportional zum Quadrat des Abstands ist. Also doppelt so weit weg ein Viertel der Anziehung.
Umso weiter weg, umso weniger zieht es sich an.
Genau. Und der Faktor ist halt das Quadrat. Dass, wenn man nur das annimmt, dass sich dann von alleine diese Ellipsenbahnen ergeben. Das war da ein großes Problem. Dass man halt irgendwie die Ellipsenbahnen vorhersagen konnte, nur dadurch, dass man dieses 1 durch R-Quadrat-Kraftgesetz angenommen hat.
Wie hat er denn das eigentlich entwickelt?
Er hat danach gesucht, wie man diese Ellipsen erklären kann.
Konkret die Ellipsenbahnen der Planeten.
Genau.
Darum ging es ihm schon. Darauf ist er dann sozusagen überhaupt erst...
Das war eins der großen Probleme. Das kam in der Zeit auf, dass da die Frage war, kann man das vielleicht durch ein Kraftgesetz erklären? Und der hat das... Jedenfalls ist das die Hauptüberlieferung. Er hat das richtig gemacht. Die genaue Geschichte ist ein bisschen schwieriger, weil der auch schon wieder in so einem Gedankenumfeld war. Da gab es auch den Herrn Huck, den irgendwie der gemeine Schüler vom Huck-Schön-Gesetz kennt, was irgendwie über die Federkräfte redet. Aber das war ein Konkurrent seiner Zeit. H-doppel-O-K-E.
K-E, Huck, okay.
Da geht nämlich das... die Sache darauf zurück, auf den Schultern von Riesen stehen. Standing on the shoulders of giants. Das hat Newton gesagt, auf die Frage, wie er denn darauf gekommen ist. Er hätte auf den Schultern von Riesen gestanden. Das ist ja normalerweise so eine unterwerfige Zitate, wo man sagt, ja, ich hab irgendwie... ich bin nur so groß, weil ich bei anderen Leuten auf den Schultern gestanden hab. Aber in Wahrheit ist das eine Spitze gegen Hooke, weil Hooke relativ klein war, der war kleinwüchsig. Und damit hat Herr Newton gesagt, auf dessen Schultern hab ich schon mal nicht gestanden.
Diese Sache mit der Kraft und der Gravitation, ich meine, wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Newton hat jetzt gelebt, 1600 bis 1700, irgendwas kann man sich gar nicht so richtig vorstellen, was damals so das verbreitete Weltbild war. Also doch, man kann sich das schon vorstellen, dass das ein sehr eingeschränktes Weltbild war und viel mit Gott und so ein Kram zu tun hatte. Aber die paar Leute, die halt wirklich wissenschaftlich gearbeitet haben, da kann ich mir immer nicht so richtig vorstellen, wie weit die eigentlich schon waren in ihrer Erkenntnis. Dass man überhaupt jetzt auf sowas kommt wie Anziehungskräfte und sich überhaupt sowas wie Gravitation dann auch erklären zu müssen, da muss man ja auch schon irgendwie...
Die eigentliche intellektuelle Leistung ist eben auch, also einerseits natürlich dieses Erklären von diesen Ellipsen, aber das ist auch in gewisser Weise der erste Schritt von einer Sache, die bis heute ganz wichtig ist, das ist dieses Konzept der Vereinheitlichung. Dass man verschiedene Phänomene, die erstmal so aussehen, als hätten sie nichts miteinander zu tun, versteht als Ausprägung des gleichen Prinzipes. Und in diesem Fall ist es die Gravitation. Die Gravitation kennt man, weil einem hier irgendwas auf den Boden fällt. Das ist diese Kraft, die dafür sorgt, oder die einen irgendwie schwer macht. Und das zu verstehen, dass das das Gleiche ist, was eben für die Planetenbewegungen verantwortlich ist.
Da gehört schon einiges zu.
Da gehört einiges dazu. Und das ist ein großer intellektueller Schritt gewesen. Und seitdem betreiben wir dieses Geschäft heute weiter.
Wir versuchen immer mehr verschiedene Phänomene, im Kleinen auch aufs Große, im Großen zu erklären.
Also der nächste Schritt war dann zum Beispiel, dass man verstanden hat, dass Elektrizität und Magnetismus im Prinzip zwei Seiten einer Medaille sind. Das war, ich bin historisch nicht so ganz fit, aber im 18. oder frühen 19. Jahrhundert, würde ich sagen, bis zum Exvils Gleichung. Und im Prinzip betreiben wir das immer noch.
Dieses Spiel, das Kleine und das Große aufeinander abzustimmen.
Genau. Und aus gemeinsamen Prinzipien zu beschreiben. Also wenn man da große Worte verwenden will, dann sagt man, wir suchen halt nach der Weltformel.
Aber wie nah ist man der Weltformel bisher gekommen? Es gibt da noch so viele, ne?
Erstaunlich weit, würde ich sagen. Also eben die String-Theorie, mit der ich mich befasse, die behauptet, so was zu sein. Die behauptet, alle Kräfte richtig zu beschreiben. Es ist halt nicht eine Formel, sondern eine ganze Theorie-Gebäude. Aber wir sind da, also da kann man noch nicht sicher sein, aber wir sind da...
Auf einem guten Weg...
.hoffen, auf einem guten Weg zu sein.
Okay. Bis dann wieder so eine ganz grundlegende Erkenntnis kommt, ihr irgendwo ein 12-Jähriger aufbringt, und dann stürzt das ganze Gebäude wieder.
Also man muss dazu natürlich auch sagen, um mal die Hybris so ein bisschen in Grenzen zu halten, das ist nicht so, dass man dann fertig ist mit der Wissenschaft, nur weil man irgendwie das eine grundlegende Prinzip gefunden hat. Das sieht man ja auch zum Beispiel, man kann halt sagen, dass alles, was Biologie unterliegt, ist eine Chemie. Und die versteht man in weiten Bereichen. Das macht die Biologie nicht überflüssig. Genauso ist die Quantenphysik die Grundlage der Chemie. Also die Gleichungen, die im Prinzip die ganzen chemischen Reaktionen beschreiben, die kennen wir. Trotzdem ist in keiner Weise die Chemie überflüssig. Nur weil wir das Prinzip verstehen, wie es funktioniert, heißt das nicht, dass es klar damit geht.
Damit geht der ganze Spaß eigentlich erst so richtig los. Genau.
Und wir wollen halt im Prinzip für die ganze Physik etwas machen, was irgendwie die Quantenphysik für die Chemie ist.
Ja, jetzt wollte ich noch mal ein bisschen weiterschreiten, weil das ist, glaube ich, auch ganz spannend, mal einfach noch mal so zu realisieren, wie ist sozusagen die Menschheit überhaupt der Sache auf die Spur gekommen. Jetzt haben wir irgendwie Newton gehabt, der hat die Äpfel fallen lassen und daraus Rückschlüsse auf die Planetenbahnen gezogen. Was war denn sozusagen seine Theorie damals, was es sich denn bei dieser Gravitation handelt? Ich meine, der Markt zwar diesen Zusammenhang hergestellt haben und so eine Formel gefunden habe, aber der wird ja dann noch nicht wirklich davon ausgegangen sein, dass da jetzt atomare Kräfte walten. Man muss ja auch irgendeine Theorie gehabt haben, was diese Kraft überhaupt erst freisetzt. Hat er sich da überhaupt mit beschäftigt oder war das dann einfach so?
Da haben wir Schwierigkeiten, weil ich kann nicht sagen, was dahinter steckt. Also man kann vielleicht Sachen auf tieferem Level verstehen, aber erst mal ist das halt einfach so eine Kraft.
Okay, der Wissenschaftler stellt einfach erst mal fest, die ist da und ich muss mir keine Gedanken darüber machen, warum, aber das treibt dann doch schon ein bisschen um, oder?
Ja, aber wenn man dann ein bisschen darüber nachdenkt, dann stellt man fest, es ist nicht ganz klar, was man da für eine Antwort erwartet. Also ob da kleine Ameisen sind, die das irgendwie an so einem Seil ziehen oder... Also was für eine Antwort erwartet man da? Also irgendwann muss man aufhören, solche Fragen auch zu stellen. Hier vielleicht noch nicht, aber...
Ja gut, aber was hat das jetzt dann sozusagen bewirkt? Also er kam mit diesen Thesen auf und hat gesagt, Leute, dass wir hier auf dem Boden stehen, das wird ein Grund haben. Da muss er ja im Prinzip auch davon ausgegangen sein, dass die Erde eine Kugel und so weiter...
Ja, das war schon lange beklärt...
.des flachen Erdes war eh schon durch. Gut, und wir sind ein Planet wie jeder andere auch. Das war auch klar zu dem Zeitpunkt. Die Sonne spielt schon eine zentrale Rolle. Das haben sie auch schon begriffen.
Genau.
Man konnte auch schon von so was wie einem Sonnensystem ausgehen und dass die anderen Planeten was mit uns zu tun haben. Aber was ist denn so mit den Sternen? Ich meine, man hat ja immer die Sterne, die hat man ja schon immer gesehen. Man guckt irgendwie nach oben, und da ist halt einfach ganz viel Licht. Wann ist man denn davon überhaupt ausgegangen, dass es sich dabei um weitere Sonnen handelt?
Das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Wenn man diese Erkenntnis gehabt hat, dass die Sonne das einzige Besondere an der Sonne ist, dass sie halt uns zufällig am nächsten ist.
Ja, eben.
Wann das historisch klar gewesen ist, da muss ich passen.
Da habe ich auch irgendwie so, als Kind auch, irgendwie erstmal eine Weile gebraucht. Das hat mir irgendwie so keiner erklärt. Ah ja klar, es sind auch nur Sonnen.
Beziehungsweise, dass eben die Planeten was anderes sind. Also das sind erstmal alles nur so Lichtpunkte. Aber dass die Sonne den anderen Lichtpunkten viel ähnlicher ist als diese Planeten. Aber wann das historisch war, weiß ich nicht. Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Aber was hat das... Also gut, jetzt haben wir sozusagen... Jahrhundert schon so eine Erkenntnislage, ist ja eigentlich schon mal ganz fett.
Ja, also das ist ein Riesen. Der war ein Gigant. Ein Physiktitan.
Und wer stand dann auf seinen Schultern?
Na ja, dann war die Sache gesettelt. Dann für lange Zeit. Also diese Gravitation war einfach geklärt.
Alle waren glücklich?
Alle waren glücklich. Bis 1915. Bis Einstein.
Spielt denn jetzt Strom-Magnetismus da an der Stelle schon noch irgendeine Rolle? Nee, überhaupt nicht. Ich meine, dass das dann miteinander schon was zu tun hat?
Genau, das waren ja auch immer so Ideen, dass vielleicht so Magnetismus ist. Aber Magnetismus ist viel unklarer gewesen. Also so ein Kraftgesetz von einem Magneten zu beschreiben, ist viel komplizierter. Weil der hat ja auch so zwei Pole und da hängt das ja von der Form ab und wenn man den irgendwie zu einem Schuh, also zu so einem Ring biegt. Also Magnetismus ist damals irgendwie komplizierter gewesen.
Und das muss doch die Leute dann irgendwie tierisch herausgefordert haben.
Ja, die haben groß... Na ja, Strom ist ja auch schwierig. Das hat man ja nicht. Also wenn man keine Steckdose hat, dann ist das ja mit dem Strom... Also Strom, Elektrizität ist erstmal die Wissenschaft von Katzenfällen und...
Ja genau, so statische Aufladung und dann Funkenflug und zack und dann macht es knack...
Funkenflug und Froschenkel, an die man irgendwie das Katzenfell dann dranhält, die dann zucken und so.
Ja.
Das ist eben das mit dem, als man dann Elektrizität verstanden hat, das hat man relativ gleichzeitig mit dem Magnetismus verstanden.
Und in Zusammenhang gebracht auch?
Und in Zusammenhang gebracht. Also die Feststellung, dass Magnetismus sozusagen die Elektrizität von bewegten Ladungen ist. Also wenn ich Ladungen hab, die sich nicht bewegen, dann hab ich halt dieses mit den zu Berge stehenden Haaren und Katzenfällen und so. Und wenn diese Ladungen sich einfach geordnet bewegen, zum Beispiel in so einem Draht, dann steht halt ein Magnetfeld um den Draht herum. Und wenn ich so einen Magneten habe, der irgendwie so ein Eisenstück ist, dann ist das letztendlich auch so. Da fliegen halt, also das wissen wir jetzt heute, das wussten die damals noch nicht so, aber da fliegen halt die Elektronen, die eben geladene Teilchen sind, geordnet in sozusagen, also Kreisbahnen stimmt nicht ganz, aber die fliegen im Prinzip im Kreis und machen deswegen auch nur einen Strom in dem Eisen. Und wenn das Eisen magnetisiert ist, dann sind die einfach ausgerichtet.
Aber wo haben die denn überhaupt, wo hat man denn überhaupt den ersten Magneten? Ich meine, die liegen lang in der Erde?
Magnete findet man in der Erde. Also da findet man Steine, die magnetisch sind.
Das heißt, irgendwann ist mal jemand aufgefallen, dass so, da muss ja wahrscheinlich auch erstmal Metall extrahiert worden sein, damit man das Bob bemerkt.
Man darf das nicht zu heiß machen, dann geht nämlich der Magneteffekt weg. Ich weiß nicht, also da hat man irgendwie Steine gefunden und da hat man irgendwie gesehen, die ziehen sich irgendwie an, so ein bisschen. Also das ist natürlich ganz schwach. Und dann kann man ja irgendwie durch, das kennt man ja aus dem Physikunterricht, durch Reiben aus einem Magneten und einem Stück Eisen einen anderen machen. Und den kann man im Prinzip dann auch stärker machen. Aber das quantitativ zu beschreiben, ist erstmal schwierig. Aber was man dann halt gesehen hat, also der Erkenntnisweg war, also man hatte das dann mit dem Strom und konnte halt auch so primitive Batterien bauen, eben indem man Metallstreifen in verschiedene Flüssigkeiten irgendwie getaucht hat. Und dann floss da irgendwie ein Strom und der bringt irgendwie Fross-Schenkel zum Zucken. Und dann hat man halt gesehen, dass wenn man halt so eine Kompass-Nadel, die hatte man eben auch, also Kompass war halt, also da ist ja Magnet für wichtig.
Stimmt, das war sonst die erste praktische Anwendung.
Und Schifffahren war ja sowieso eine Riesensache. Und zu wissen, in welche Richtung man fährt, also ich meine, wir alle jetzt mit GPS, aber... Aber schon mal die Richtung ist ja schon mal eine gute Sache zu wissen. Und deswegen war das halt, es hatte halt sofort technologische Anwendung, dieser Magnetgeschichte. Und dann hatte man halt gesehen, dass wenn man so eine Magnetnadel in der Nähe von einem Draht hat, wo halt Strom durchfließt, dass diese Magnetnadel so ein bisschen zu zucken anfängt. Und dann hat man das angefangen, genauer zu untersuchen. Das war auch irgendwie eine Heldentat, da dann ein quantitives Gesetz rauszukriegen. Also rauszumessen, wie stark die Kraft ist, wie die von dem Strom abhängt, wie die von dem Abstand abhängt, wie die von der Form, in der ich den Draht gelegt habe, durch den der Strom durchfließt.
Ja, aber zurück zu den Planeten und der Gravitation. Manche haben da schon irgendwie Newton eine Menge gemacht. Dann waren sie alle erstmal ganz zufrieden und haben gesagt, ok, alles klar, wir drehen uns um die Sonne, super. Jetzt gehen wir wieder kegeln. Aber dann kam Einstein. Ich meine, war das jetzt wirklich so, dass gar nichts passiert ist und keiner hat sich darum gekümmert?
Nein, das war einfach geklärt. Also Astronomen gab es schon und die haben da auch gerechnet, aber neue Grundlegenderkenntnisse waren nicht nötig. Weil man wusste einfach, wie es funktioniert.
Aber was meinte man sich denn damit, alles erklären zu können? Das erklärt alle himmlischen Bewegungen. Irgendwann muss man doch mal auch realisiert haben, dass diese anderen Lichtpunkte auch Sonnen sind.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das war auch schon lange klar.
Ja gut, wir wissen zwar jetzt nicht, wann es eingesetzt hat, aber wie hat man sich denn das dann sozusagen, also, da war dann schon der Begriff einer Galaxis in dem Sinne schon geboren oder war das halt einfach dann so, das Universum hat viele Sonnen und die sind irgendwo und wahrscheinlich ziemlich weit weg?
Also irgendwann, auch da weiß ich wieder nicht, welcher Name daran hängt, welche Jahreszeit das war, aber irgendwann hatte man halt so ein Fernrohr. Also was man sehen konnte, waren halt Nebel. Also es gibt halt diese Lichtpunkte, eben die Sterne. Da kann man so viel vergrößern, wie man will. Die bleiben immer ein Punkt.
Ja.
Und dann gibt es diese Nebel. Diesen Orion-Nebel, kennt man den, kann man irgendwie. Orion finden, glaube ich, viele Leute am Himmel, gerade jetzt im Winter. Das ist halt so ein einfaches Sternbild. Also ich kann das jetzt schwer beschreiben, aber Orion kennen irgendwie viele Leute. Sieht man am Winterhimmel. Und wenn man dem zwischen die Beine guckt, dann ist da ein etwas hellerer Fleck. Ach so, das erste, was man natürlich gesehen hat, ist die Milchstraße. Also es gibt halt dieses hellschimmernde Band, was der städtische Bewohner nicht kennt, weil es in der Stadt zu hell ist.
Ein bisschen in die Pampa fährt.
Da gibt es vor allem ein Band, wo es einfach ein bisschen heller ist. Und das ist auch fest. Also das verändert sich nicht. Und irgendwann hat man halt Fernrohre so gut gehabt, dass man feststellen konnte, dieses Helle, das sind lauter andere Lichtpunkte. Also das ist einfach das gesamte Licht von ganz vielen kleinen dunklen Punkten. Und dann gibt es halt diese anderen Nebel, wurden die genannt, eben wie diesen Orion-Nebel, also zwischen den Beinen vom Orion. Also mit dem Feldstecher sieht man das auf jeden Fall. Und wenn man da dann hinguckt, und wieder genau hinguckt, sieht man auch, das sind, die bestehen aus lauter kleinen Punkten. Und dann kommt man eben auf die Idee, das sind auch lauter Sterne und die sind halt nur weit weg. Und es sind verdammt viele. Und dann kann man eben auch kapieren, dass diese Milchstraße, dass wir halt auch in so einem Fleck drin sind. Und die Innenansicht ist halt so ein Band, weil es halt eine Scheibe ist. Und wenn man in einer Scheibe drin ist, dann sieht man im Wesentlichen ein Band, was sich einmal über den Himmel windet. Und damit war klar, es geht halt immer weiter.
Für die anderen sind wir auch nur Nebel. Damit war klar, es geht immer weiter. Das heißt, es sind so dermaßen viele Sonnen da draußen, dass es überhaupt gar keinen Ansatz gibt, überhaupt erst mal zu zählen, wie viel es denn eigentlich wirklich sind.
Also zumindest ein Zeitpunkt. Also die Erkenntnis, die man immer hat, ist, es ist alles generisch. Also erst einmal gedacht, irgendwie die Erde ist einzigartig. Und dann irgendwie ist die Erde degradiert worden zu einem von neun Planeten. Oder damals halt noch weniger. Dann ist irgendwie die Sonne zu, von dem Hauptstern zu einem von vielen Sternen in der Miehstraße degradiert worden. Und dann ist irgendwie klar geworden, die Miehstraße ist halt auch nur so ein ganz ordinärer.
Und wir sind auch nicht der Mittelpunkt unserer Galaxis, sondern wie Douglas Adams das so schön sagte, irgendwo in einem westlichen Spiral ab.
Genau. Mostly harmless.
Mostly harmless, genau.
Und es gibt, also überall wo man hinguckt, sieht es eigentlich genauso aus. Also, im Mittel.
Wie langweilig. Wir sind gewöhnlich. Da hatten, glaube ich, echt eine ganze Menge Leute wirklich Probleme mit, vor allem die Kirche. Tja, das heißt, es hat sich also schon vor Einstein im Prinzip vollkommen durchgesetzt, die Überzeugung, wir haben da also unser Sternensystem mit unseren Planeten und derer gibt es eine ganze Menge andere. Und offensichtlich sind wir wohl eher Teil von diesem Lichtband, weil das scheint uns ja recht nah zu sein.
Und zu umgeben. Es ist halt einmal rundrum.
Es ist einmal rundrum, wir sind also irgendwie mitten drin und nicht nur so am Rand. Also jetzt müssen wir nicht komplett am Rand.
Ja, aber wir sind halt auch nicht in der Mitte.
Okay.
Was übrigens auch gut ist.
Ja, da kommen wir sicherlich noch zu. Hatte man denn, ich meine, diese Häufung als solche, also kann man ja mal sagen, ist halt die Galaxis. Galaxis sind halt viele Sternensysteme und gibt es dann schon sozusagen eine Erklärung dafür, dass es so eine Häufung überhaupt gibt?
Na ja, das folgt eben schon aus diesem Newtonischen Gravitationsgesetz. Wenn halt Massen sich anziehen, dann fallen die aufeinander und klumpen.
Ja gut, aber dann müsste ja irgendwann alles an einer einzigen Stelle sich zusammenklumpen und dann ist es irgendwie wieder eins.
Na ja, außer wenn es halt schnell genug auseinanderfliegt. Also das ist was, das halt balanciert.
War das sozusagen schon in der Denke von Newton mit drin?
Also ob der das nur selber gedacht hat, weiß ich nicht. Aber da brauchte man keine weitere, also Nachdenken in die richtige Richtung hätte ihn da drauf jedenfalls bringen können.
So, und dann?
Der nächste, ja, beziehungsweise auch von der Beobachtung her, also irgendwie in den Himmel gucken ist ja eine schöne Sache und irgendwie mit Fernrohren gucken ist auch eine schöne Sache, weil man sieht halt mehr. Und dann fängt man halt auch, sobald man irgendwie fotografieren kann, fängt man an das zu fotografieren, was man durchs Fernrohr durchsieht. Und das hat halt den Vorteil, dass man damit, indem man sehr lange belichtet, Sachen fotografieren kann, die man mit dem Auge nicht sehen kann, weil sie zu dunkel sind. Und dann kann man halt noch mal viel mehr entdecken, indem man einfach mal ein paar Stunden so ein Foto belichtet.
Ja. Und auch sozusagen auf irgendeinen Teil des Himmels ausgerichtet, der auf den ersten Blick einfach nur schwarz ist. Ja, oder? Dann stellt man auf einmal fest, so schwarz ist der gar nicht.
Genau. Und das andere, was man eben noch machen kann, ist, dass man nicht nur direkt abbildet, also nicht nur schöne Bilder macht, sondern dass man versucht, dieses Licht von den Sternen zu analysieren, also konkret das Spektrum anzugucken. Also Newton hat schon selber, vielleicht nicht mit Sternenlicht, aber Newton war auch fasziniert von so einem Prisma, wie das Sonnenlicht irgendwie in die ganzen Farben aufspaltet. Und das erweist sich auch als sehr klug, wenn man das mit Sternenlicht macht. Konkret macht man das nicht mit einem Prisma, sondern mit einem Gitter, aber der Effekt ist der gleiche. Man zerlegt das Licht nach verschiedenen Frequenzen und kann daraus sehr viel lernen. Also da sieht man, das ist nämlich nicht so ein kontinuierliches Spektrum, wie man das so kennt, auf der einen Seite rot, auf der anderen Seite violett, also kein Regenbogen. Das ist schon ein Regenbogen, aber da fehlen einzelne, da sind einzelne dunkle Striche drin. Das hat dazu geführt, beziehungsweise, es gibt auch mal den umgekehrten Effekt, man kennt ja diese orangenen Straßenlaternen, diese Natriumdampflampen. Vielleicht ist dir das auch schon mal aufgefallen, wenn du in der Nacht, also ich weiß gar nicht, in Berlin gibt es auch die, Berlin hat Gaslampen, die sind weiß, aber in vielen Städten und auch in anderen Ländern, hier gibt es diese orangenen Straßenlampen. Belgische Autobahnen fallen einem ein, genau.
Also die meisten sind Quetsch-Zimmerdampflampen.
Oder Natriumdampflampen.
Aber halt so diese orangenen gelblichen.
Genau, mit denen kann man halt für wenig Strom viel Licht erzeugen. Aber der Nachteil ist, man sieht keine Farben mehr.
Ja, weil es halt nur so ist.
Alle Katzen sind grau und alles ist irgendwie orange. Und wenn man halt dieses Licht von diesen Natriumdampflampen durch den Prisma anguckt, dann sieht man, da gibt es nur zwei, im Wesentlichen genau zwei Linien. Die sind beide im orangenen Bereich und ganz dicht zusammen.
Also ein sehr reines Orangelicht sozusagen.
Genau, und deswegen sieht man eben keine Farben mehr.
Weil es halt nicht reflektiert wird.
Weil es überhaupt nicht erzeugt wird. Das Licht fliegt halt gar nicht mehr rum. Es gibt halt nur oranges Licht und die Sachen sind entweder orange oder nicht. Also reflektieren entweder orange ins Licht oder nicht. Aber es sind zwei sehr genaue Linien. Und das zu verstehen, warum, wie es zu diesen Linien kommt, das hat in einer anderen Entwicklung letztendlich zu der Quantentheorie geführt. Weil das damit zusammenhängt, dass die Elektronen in den Atomen und Molekülen nur in bestimmten Zuständen, sich in diskreten Zuständen aufhalten können. Und wenn die zwischen zwei von diesen diskreten Zuständen sich hin und her bewegen, senden sie halt genau dieses Licht von einer ganz bestimmten Wellenlänge aus.
Wir müssen noch mal ins Atom reisen. Aber bevor wir das tun, wollte ich noch mal kurz bei dieser Weltenbetrachtung hängen, einfach auch mal so ein bisschen zu verstehen, wie so eigentlich so die wissenschaftliche Situation, Gesamtsituation war Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts. Ich glaube, das ist ja dann so der Punkt, wo dann so die größere Wende eingeleitet wurde. Also wir hatten irgendwie Weltall und so weiter. Das wurde so generell zur Kenntnis genommen, dass es da wohl eine ganze Menge Sonnen gibt. Die Ausdehnung dieses Weltalls, denke ich mal, dürfte auch den Leuten eine ganze Menge Fragen gestellt haben.
Genau, also man konnte das noch nicht so genau messen, aber das sieht halt schon sehr groß aus und es gibt irgendwie, man sieht, kein Ende abzusehen.
Trotzdem lässt sich ja eigentlich auch leicht behaupten, also kann man ja auch, wenn ich das richtig sehe, kann man ja sagen, das kann nicht unendlich groß sein, weil wenn es irgendwie unendlich groß wäre, dann gäbe es ja auch unendlich viele Sonnen und dann...
So what?
Hätte man da nicht einfach nur überall Licht?
Okay, das ist ein, das heißt, diese Frage ist das sogenannte Olbers Paradox. Ja. Das erklärt am Ende nur die Raumkrümmung, warum das nicht so ist. Also der Witz ist einfach, dass halt dann ein bisschen oder gewaltig später, in der zweiten Hälfte des 20. Jahrhunderts klar geworden ist, dass sich das Welt halt ausdehnt und deswegen wird es halt dünn nach außen. Aber sonst hast du recht, wenn dem nicht so wäre, dann würde einfach der ganze Himmel hell, gleichmäßig hell sein.
Okay, also es könnte auch nach wie vor unendlich groß sein, sozusagen.
Und die Erkenntnis, dass man halt nicht, wenn man sich selber intellektuell immer weiter aus dem Mittelpunkt entfernt, ist das eigentlich auch die natürliche Annahme.
Aber welche Fragen, ich meine, wenn die jetzt alle so glücklich waren, so ja, okay, alles klar, es gibt Sonnensterne, es gibt Galaxien, und dann gibt es noch ein paar mehr Galaxien, und die liegen da irgendwie alle rum, und super, und jetzt gehen wir wieder nach Hause. Was war denn sozusagen das große Rätsel? Also gab es denn irgendetwas, was man sich nicht erklären konnte, und wo sie alle drunter gelitten haben? Oder waren eigentlich alle total zufrieden mit dem Zustand und es ist doch super?
Genau, also es gab halt verschiedene parallele Bewegungen. Das eine ist das mit den Atomen, der Quantenphysik. Und eben diesen schwarzen Linien in den Sternenspektren. Also die Sternenspektren sind genau das Umgekehrte von diesen Natrium-Lampen.
Genau, die haben nur zweimal irgendwie orange Punkte. Bei den anderen hatten die eigentlich alle Farben bis auf ein paar.
Bis auf ein paar. Und das liegt eben daran, dass eben genau diese Übergänge von den Atomen da angerichtet werden und dafür das Licht absorbiert. Aber die sind sehr genau geeicht. Also die liegen halt an bestimmten Frequenzen. Ja, also ich weiß jetzt nicht die Zahl von dem Natrium, aber...
Ach so, jetzt bei den Natrium-Lampen.
Ja, also das ist charakteristisch für das chemische Element. Bei welchen Frequenzen? Also Natrium hat halt diese zwei Linien im Orangenen. Und Wasserstoff hat irgendwo anders seine Linien. Und also die Sterne bestehen ja hauptsächlich aus Wasserstoff. Und ein bisschen Helium. Also daher weiß man das überhaupt aus, was für Elementen die bestehen, weil man halt gucken kann, welche Linien sind in den Spektren drin. Und dann macht man auf der Erde ein Experiment, macht halt Wasserstoff warm und guckt, was für Linien das hat.
Und dann hat man das gemacht.
Das war der heiße Scheiß Ende des 19., Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts.
Das heißt, man hat sozusagen angefangen zu sagen, jetzt schauen wir uns mal das Einzige an, was wir uns wirklich anschauen können, nämlich das Licht. Und versuchen dann sozusagen Schlussfolgen rauszumachen. Und so konnte man dann bestimmen. Und dann hat man dann gesagt, okay, alles klar, die Sonne...
Wasserstoff....
muss irgendwie im Wesentlichen aus Wasserstoff bestehen, weil sie einfach ein entsprechendes Spektrum abgibt.
Genau, weil sie das Spektrum abgibt, was wir auch bei uns zu Hause im Labor irgendwie reproduzieren können. So, das ist die eine Sache. Da hat man dann später gesehen, dass weiter entfernte Sterne, da sind diese Linien verschoben. Man sieht das gleiche Muster an Linien, aber die sind gleichmäßig in der Frequenz verschoben.
Also man weiß auch, es sind auch Wasserstoff, es sind auch Sterne wie alle anderen auch. Die brennen jetzt nicht anders.
Nein, nein.
Die stehen nicht aus irgendwas anderem. Aber diese Linien sind woanders.
Genau. Und da ist die Lösung dieser Dopplereffekt. Also was man immer mit dem Krankenwagen beschreibt, der erst mit Tatütata auf einen zufährt, dann ist der Ton höher. Also wenn er auf einen zufährt, ist der Ton höher. Und wenn er von einem wegfährt, ist der Ton tiefer. Weil die Wellen, wenn er auf einen zufährt, werden sie zusammengestaucht, die Tonwellen. Und wenn er wegfährt, werden sie auseinandergezogen. Und das Gleiche passiert mit dem Licht.
Das heißt, etwas, was auf mich zufährt, hat eine höhere Frequenz. Und das, was von mir wegfährt, ist dunkler.
Nein, nicht dunkler, röter.
Röter. Also verschiebt sich in der Farbfrequenz in eine andere Richtung. Und rot ist auf der niedrigfrequenten Seite. Und das violette ist auf der hochfrequenten Seite. Das heißt, wenn es mehr ins violett geht, dann...
Dann kommt es auf mich zu.
Dann bewegt sich das auf mich zu. Und wenn es rot ist, dann bewegt sich das von mir weg. Und was hat man dann gesehen? Wohin bewegt sich dann so alles hin? Weg. Alles.
Die Tendenz ist weg.
Aber es gibt auch etwas, was sich zu mir bewegt. Oder nicht?
Ja, aber eher zufällig. Also da gibt es natürlich statistische Flukationen. Aber die wesentliche Tendenz ist, es fliegt alles von uns weg. Und zwar je weiter weg, desto schneller.
Ah, okay, das heißt, oh.
Das kann einen jetzt erst mal wieder dazu führen, dass man denkt, man steht im Mittelpunkt. Wir haben jetzt gerade übrigens nochmal einen 50-Jahre-Sprung gemacht. In welche Richtung? Also wir sind jetzt irgendwie 2. Hälfte 20. Jahrhundert.
Oha, da dürfen wir ja noch gar nicht hin.
Und die andere halt dann natürlichere Entdeckung ist, dass sich der Raum unten drunter ausdehnt. Das Bild, was man da immer verwendet, ist, wenn ich einen Luftballon habe und dann wie lauter Punkte draufmache und dann anfange, den aufzublasen. Und dann stelle ich mir vor, ich bin eine Ame, also die auf einem der Punkte steht, dann sieht sie, und sie guckt halt zu sich die anderen Punkte in ihrer Umgebung an, dann sieht sie, wenn der Luftballon aufgeblasen wird, dass auch alle Punkte weggehen von ihr. Und zwar je weiter die Punkte weg sind, desto schneller gehen sie weg von ihr.
Verstehe, weil sich alles gleichmäßig aufbläht.
Genau, weil alles, was sich um den Faktor 2 irgendwie vergrößert und was halt schon weit weg war, dann macht halt der Faktor 2 mehr aus 1.
Aber das heißt, diese Licht-Experimenten waren aber jetzt sozusagen auch noch Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts. Das heißt, da hat man im Prinzip schon, oder war jetzt diese eigentliche Entdeckung mit der Ausdehnung, die kam dann erst später?
Das kam erst später.
Okay. Das heißt, am Anfang hat man das überhaupt erst mal betrieben und wusste dann erst mal, woraus überhaupt alles besteht. Und konnte sich das anschauen. Aber diese Unterschiede im Spektrum, die hat man sozusagen, hat man die dann erst später entdeckt oder hat man erst später dafür die Bedeutung gefunden? Also, ich wollte immer noch so ein bisschen darauf...
Man muss schon Sachen angucken, die ziemlich weit wechseln.
Ja, aber was war sozusagen die Fragestellung? Also, waren ja eigentlich alle glücklich und zufrieden. Man hatte irgendwie so Universum, wir sitzen da irgendwo drin und so, es gibt Sterne, super, alles klar. Was hat jetzt die Leute eigentlich wirklich beschäftigt? Also, was war das große Fragezeichen?
Also, es gab ganz viele Fragezeichen. Und das eine war eben, zu verstehen, wie das zu diesen diskreten Spektren kommt. Das hat zu der Quantenphysik geführt. Und das andere war, dass man halt, inzwischen hatte man die Gleichung von der elektromagnetischen Theorie, also die sogenannten Maxwell-Gleichungen gefunden. Und bei denen hat eben Einstein festgestellt, dass die nicht verträgt, dass die eine ausgezeichnete Geschwindigkeit haben. Also ich nehme diese Gleichung, die ich eben mit den Katzenfällen und den Magnetnadeln an den Drähten mir irgendwie in einer Meisterleistung zusammengereimt habe. Und dann kann ich aus diesen Gleichungen diese elektromagnetischen Wellen, kommen Fallen aus den Gleichungen aus. Diese Gleichungen sagen, hier guck, es gibt nicht nur irgendwie zu Berge stehende Haare, sondern diese elektromagnetischen Felder, die breiten sich auch wellenartig aus. Das folgt das viel aus diesen Maxwell-Gleichungen raus. Und da wurden diese elektromagnetischen Wellen vorhergesagt und dann hat irgendwie Herz, die auch tatsächlich dann produzieren können. Das hat aber eine Weile gedauert. Und es ist auch vollkommen klar, dass diese Wellen breiten sich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit aus. Das folgt einfach aus den Gleichungen. Aus den Maxwell-Gleichungen. Und zwar in jede Richtung gleich. Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist eine universelle Konstanz.
Also, dass es sich bei Licht um eine Welle handelt, das hatte man sozusagen schon verinnerlicht, oder?
Ja, zu Newtons Zeit war das noch heiß umkämpft, ob Licht Teilchen oder Wellen sind. Newton hat geglaubt, es sei ein Teilchen.
Aber den Begriff Teilchen und Welle gab es schon damals bei Newton.
Der sprach ja irgendwie, wenn der wissenschaftlich redete, sprach der ja lateinisch. Das war aber die große Frage. Das ist geklärt worden, erst nachdem man feststellen konnte, ob das Licht, wenn es durch ein Medium durchgeht, also zum Beispiel durch Wasser, ob die Lichtgeschwindigkeit steigt oder langsamer wird. Da kann man sich überlegen, dass, wenn das Licht aus Teilchen bestehen würde, zumindest in der damaligen Version, müsste das im Medium schneller laufen, um die Brechungsgesetze richtig zu beschreiben. Und Wellen müssten langsamer laufen. Das hat man dann halt untersuchen können. Man muss halt die Lichtgeschwindigkeit messen, man muss so einen Druck Wasser dazwischen stellen, dann müsste man nochmal die Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Ja, ja. Im Mathe ist es langsamer. Das hat das zu den Wellen entschieden.
Guck ein. Ich dachte, Lichtgeschwindigkeit wäre so eine wunderbare Konstante.
Im Vakuum.
Aber so bei uns?
Im Glas ist sie ein Faktor, ist sie um 50% langsamer.
50%?
Ja. Der Brechungsindex ist, der Brechungsindex ist 1,5 ungefähr von Glas. Und das ist genau der Faktor, um den es langsamer ist.
Also sie müht sich schon sozusagen ganz schön durch das Zeug.
Genau.
Das ist auch schön zu sehen, dass sogar das Licht manchmal so seine Schwierigkeiten hat.
Aber zurück zum Licht im Vakuum. Das ist Folger aus den Max-Vergleichungen. Das muss immer gleich sein. Und nun hat irgendwie Einstein sich das, hat da irgendwie in seinem berühmten Patentamt in Zürich gesessen und sich überlegt, dass das hier irgendwie schwer damit verträglich ist. Wie ist denn das, wenn ich mich bewege? Also wir haben ja gerade gesehen, also wenn ich zum Beispiel Schallwellen, da gibt es ja auch erstmal eine Schallgeschwindigkeit. Die hängt nun von vielen Dingen ab, irgendwie von der Temperatur und der Dichte der Luft und solchen Sachen, aber erstmal, wenn wir das alles gleich halten, ist die auch eine Konstante. Aber wenn ich mich bewege, relativ zur Luft, dann ist relativ zur Luft die Schallgeschwindigkeit in alle Richtungen gleich. Und wenn ich mich relativ zur Luft bewege, kommt natürlich der Schall in meiner Bewegungsrichtung nicht so schnell voran, von mir aus gesehen. Und nach hinten weg läuft da halt meine eigene Geschwindigkeit plus die Schallgeschwindigkeit weg.
Obwohl ja der Tatütateffekt genau andersrum ist.
Nee, nee, das ist konsistent damit.
Na, ich laufe weg und nach hinten ist es ja nicht schneller.
Also relativ zur Luft ist es gleich, aber zu... Also wenn ich als der, der läuft, wenn ich das angucke, läuft es halt relativ zur Luft und ich laufe nochmal auch relativ zur Luft, aber in die andere Richtung. Und deswegen... Also da muss ich das überlegen, wie das mit den Wellen... Also ist es halt in dem Radiomedium nicht so. Ich könnte ja, wenn ich eine Tafel hätte, würde ich...
Jaja, jetzt kommt die eigentliche Herausforderung. Vielleicht muss man einfach das richtige... Ich meine, ist Luft jetzt wirklich das beste Beispiel? Irgendwie so? Lässt sich das so ohne weiteres?
Ja.
Für Tatütata ja, aber auch für das, was jetzt... Also nochmal, was hat Einstein gestört? Also die Behauptung war, in einem Vakuum ist die Lichtgeschwindigkeit immer konstant.
Genau.
So. Und jetzt hat er sich darüber Gedanken gemacht, was passiert, wenn ich mich jetzt in diesem Vakuum befinde.
Und mich bewege.
Und mich bewege. Aber ich imitiere jetzt in dem Sinne kein Licht.
Aber wenn du es tätest...
Also davon geht ja sozusagen aus. Ich bin so eine kleine Sonne und ich imitiere irgendwie Licht. Und jetzt bewege ich mich irgendwie nach vorne.
Genau.
Und was ihn umgetrieben hat, ist, ob denn jetzt sozusagen nach vorne, also in meine Bewegungsrichtung, das Licht dadurch beschleunigt wird oder nicht.
Und was war so seine These und Vorstellung? Oder was hat man so geglaubt? Welche Annahme galt es zu überprüfen?
Es galt zu überprüfen, ob es sich verhält wie bei dem Schall. Ob es eben so ist, dass, wenn ich laufe, dass es dann noch irgendwie schneller wird in der Einrichtung. Und dann gab es ein berühmtes Experiment von den Herren Microson und Morley. Die haben das untersucht. Die haben die Lichtgeschwindigkeit gemessen. Die haben die Bewegung der Erde auf der Bahn um die Sonne benutzt. Die haben einmal die Lichtgeschwindigkeit in Richtung zur Sonne hin und weg gemessen. Und einmal in Richtung der Erdbewegung. Nach vorne und nach hinten. Und die Erde bewegt sich relativ schnell um die Sonne rum. Und da hätte man einen Unterschied sehen müssen. Also man hat...
Also ich meine, wie misst man denn bitte das Licht?
Also banal würde man einfach blitzen, einen Spiegel aufstellen auf der anderen Seite und gucken, wann man...
Ja gut, aber man kriegt ja jetzt auf der Sonne keinen Spiegel aufgestellt.
Nein, nein, man macht das auf der Erde. Man nimmt einen relativ... Man hat auf der Erde eine Lampe und einen Spiegel, den man möglichst weit weg stellt. Und dann macht man, dann blitzt man und misst die Zeit, die vom Blitzen vergeht, bis ich das Licht wieder sehe, was von dem Spiegel zurückkommt. Und das mache ich einmal in der Richtung, in der die Erde fliegt, und einmal in der Richtung. Das mache ich aber auf der Erdoberfläche. Also ich weiß nicht, wie groß der in Aufbau war, aber...
Wir haben jetzt keine Raumschiffe losgeschickt.
Konkret macht man das... Das kann man natürlich nicht schnell genug gucken mit den Blitzen. Also konkret macht man das irgendwie dadurch, dass man so eine Blende hat, die sich irgendwie dreht. Und man macht auch einen Spiegel, der sich dreht. Und dann kann ich je nachdem, wie lange das gebraucht hat...
Die Ablenkung.
Die Ablenkung kann... Also so macht man das.
Pfff, pfff, pfff.
Wir haben das noch in der Schule gemacht auch. Es gab einen Physikleistungskurs.
Nicht schlecht.
Da kann man das einmal durch den Physikraum... Da sieht man die Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Da sieht man insbesondere auch, dass sie endlich ist. Also, dass das Licht braucht. Ja, und das hat man gemessen.
Und hat er was festgestellt?
Die Lichtgeschwindigkeit hängt nicht von der Richtung an.
Das heißt...
Es kann nicht funktionieren wie beim Schall.
Okay. Ist was anderes.
Ist was anderes. Ist aber so wie diese Max-Vergleichung, das wir hier sagen. Die Max-Vergleichungen haben sozusagen recht.
Aber auf der Erde hat man natürlich jetzt auch keine Vakuum-Bedingungen. Man hat ja in jeder Richtung irgendwie unter denselben Bedingungen gemessen. Von daher war es wahrscheinlich... Hatte man da keine Angst, dass da irgendwie nicht die Temperatur oder der Wind...
Das kann man ja auch untersuchen. Man kann ja auch irgendwie dann nochmal gucken, welchen Einfluss das hat.
Okay, gut. Das konnte ausgerottet werden. Gut, das heißt, egal, wie schnell ich mich bewege...
Die Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist immer gleich.
Genau, das ist anders als beim Schall. Weil beim Schall gibt es ja dieses Medium Luft. Und vorher dachte man, es gäbe halt auch für das Licht ein Medium. Das ist der Ether. Durch die berühmten Ether-Wellen.
Das, wo wir jetzt gerade durchsprechen.
Genau. Aber dieses Experiment hat gezeigt, es gibt den Ether nicht.
There is no Ether.
Genau. Und das geht nur durchs Vakuum. Und das hat halt dazu geführt, dass man das Einstein gesagt hat, ja, dann ist das wohl doch alles, wie wir uns das gedacht haben, mit den Längen und... Also, Einsteinsleistung war dann daraus eben auch zu folgern, was das für Konsequenzen hat. Und das aufzulösen.
Er hat erst mal drüber nachgedacht, aber diesen Test haben dann diese Leute auf Basis der ersten Überlegungen von Einstein gemacht.
Also man hat halt diese Maxwell-Gleichung. Aus den Maxwell-Gleichungen kam das schon raus, dass die Lichtgeschwindigkeit in alle Richtungen gleich sein müsste. Und dann hat er gesagt, hier guckt mal die Gleichung an. Wir wissen eigentlich, dass das die Elektrizität gut beschreibt, aber diese Gleichungen sagen, Überraschung, Überraschung, die Lichtgeschwindigkeit kann nicht von der Bewegung aushängen.
Lässt sich das irgendwie zusammenfassen, wie diese Gleichungen das behaupten, ohne dass man jetzt einen mathematischen Diskurs macht? Also ich meine, was hat das mit dem Strom und der Lichtgeschwindigkeit zu tun?
Na ja, aus dem Strom kommen halt diese elektromagnetischen Wellen raus. Und die kommen halt raus mit einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit. Und die Geschwindigkeit wird einfach bestimmt, da gibt es halt zwei Konstanten drin. Da kennt man aus dem Schulunterricht vielleicht, die heißen Epsilon und Mu. Und die eine Konstante sagt, wenn ich zwei Ladungen habe, wie stark ziehen die sich an? Da gibt es auch so ein inverses Abstandsgesetz. Und da gibt es noch eine Umrechnungsgröße, die von den Ladungen umrechnet auf die Kraft. Das ist Epsilon. Und das Gleiche gibt es noch mal für Magnete. Und es stellt sich heraus, dass die Lichtgeschwindigkeit zum Quadrat einfach das Produkt von Epsilon und Mu ist. Da kommt einfach Epsilon mal Mu, ist 300.000 Kilometer pro Sekunde irgendwie. Und das ist diese Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Und da kommt nicht vor, wie schnell sich das alles bewegt.
Was, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen verwirrend ist, dieser Begriff Lichtgeschwindigkeit, bezieht sich ja sozusagen gar nicht nur auf Licht, sondern es ist ja eigentlich die Geschwindigkeit von elektromagnetischen Wellen an sich.
Genau.
Wobei Licht da eben eine Variante davon ist.
Genau. Und Einstein hat dann festgestellt, dass man dieses Rätsel, wie das sein kann, dass es nicht nach vorne schneller läuft, dadurch auflösen kann, dass er sagt, ja, aber in Wahrheit ist das so, dass Längen, die ich messe, auch von meiner Geschwindigkeit abhängen. Und dass die Zeit, die vergeht für mich, auch von meiner Geschwindigkeit abhängt. Das ist die spezielle Relativitätstheorie.
Die er aufgestellt hat.
Die er aufgestellt hat 1905.
Das noch mal ganz langsam. Also er meint, gut, es ist klar, die Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist immer gleich. Ich bewege mich im Raum, im Vakuum. Aber dass ich das messe, dass das immer gleich ist, liegt gar nicht daran, dass es gleich ist, sondern nur, dass ich es gleich wahrnehme, weil sich ja auch irgendwie meine Vorstellung von Abstand ändert.
Und sich Zeitintervall anpassen. Das ist eben relativ zum Beobachter. Deswegen heißt es Relativitätstheorie.
Jetzt kommt ja ein interessanter neuer Begriff ins Spiel, nämlich die Zeit. Was für eine Bedeutung hatte denn die Zeit bis dahin? Was hat man denn über die Zeit gedacht? Hat sich überhaupt irgendjemand über die Zeit Gedanken gemacht? Ist Zeit überhaupt etwas, was...
Nein, die ganzen Philosophen bis zu Kant und so haben sich natürlich auch schon groß verbreitert dazu.
Ja, habe ich mal so rein jetzt auf diesen...
Aber zu dieser Newtonischen Physik gehört halt eine absolute Zeit. Die ist für alle gleich, immer und überall...
Zeit spielt keine Rolle.
Es gibt nur eine einzige und die bestimmt halt alles. Die ist an allen Orten hier und in Timbuktu die gleiche.
Und das hat im Prinzip Einstein aber in Frage gestellt.
Genau, aufgelöst. Er hat gesagt, meine Zeit hängt davon ab, wie schnell ich mich bewege. Also ich messe natürlich ab meiner eigenen Uhr. Und ob das nur meine Armwanduhr ist oder irgendwie mein Herzschlag oder dass ich so und so viel Jahre alt werde und irgendwie altere. Das sind ja alles irgendwie Uhren. Also keine Uhr ist irgendwie von der anderen unterschieden. Und das hängt von meiner Geschwindigkeit ab.
Was heißt das im Prinzip? Umso schneller ich mich bewege, desto?
Wenn ich, desto langsamer vergeht meine Zeit.
Das heißt, wenn ich mich in Lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen würde...
Dann würde sie still stehen. Aber ich kann mich nicht wirklich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit finden. Die steht einfach still.
Das heißt, Zeit und Lichtgeschwindigkeit oder die Geschwindigkeit der elektronischen Wellen hängt unmittelbar zusammen.
Genau.
Es ist Teil derselben Soße. Und man hebt die Zeit auf, wenn man sich in Lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegt. Das heißt ja dann im Umkehrschluss, wenn ich mich nicht in Lichtgeschwindigkeit bewege, dann bin ich der maximalen Zeit ausgesetzt.
Für mich selber bewege ich mich ja immer nicht. Also ich kann es ja immer so sehen, dass irgendwie die Landschaft an mir am Zug vorbeigezogen wird. Also das ist eben auch eine der wesentlichen Beobachtungen.
Genau, dann bewegen wir uns ja gerade wirklich in atemberaubendem Tempo. Das kommt ja auf den Startpunkt an. Ja gut, aber wenn wir jetzt auf diesem Planeten sind, der dreht sich irgendwie mit großer Geschwindigkeit um die Sonne, die sich selber wiederum in großer Geschwindigkeit um viele andere Sonnen dreht.
Um das Zentrum der Milchstraße rumfliegt und die Milchstraße fliegt auch noch durch die Gegend.
Was haben wir denn so für eine Geschwindigkeit? Das kann man aber gar nicht bestimmen, oder kann man das bestimmen? Das ist sozusagen auch wieder eine sehr relative Geschichte.
Genau, also erstens macht das nicht wirklich Sinn, irgendwie absolut zu sagen, weil, wie gesagt, wenn ich im Zug sitze, kann ich auch sagen, ich stehe still und die Landschaft wird unter mir lang gezogen.
Aber man kann es halt immer relativ zu anderen sagen. Das Bild mit dem Luftballon wieder aufgreifen und sozusagen so einen anderen Ameisenpunkt irgendwie jetzt mal so nehmen und dann messen, wie schnell wir uns eigentlich relativ zu dem bewegen. Da sind wir schon ganz ordentlich unterwegs.
Ja, aber auch, also nicht wirklich in der Nähe der Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Also genau, das ist...
Genau, das wäre nämlich die Frage, wie schnell ist sozusagen diese Bewegung im Raum im Verhältnis zu der Lichtgeschwindigkeit?
Prozentbereich, glaube ich. Aber nagel mich nicht fest. Man sieht das aber genau mit der Ameise. Die Ameise sieht nämlich, dass es doch eine Tendenz gibt, dass in der einen Richtung die Sachen schneller wegfliegen als in der anderen.
Na gut, aber hast du mit Prozent jetzt ein Prozent oder ein paar Prozent? Jetzt habe ich nicht.
Jetzt kann ich irgendwie anfangen zu googeln.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja auch schon mal eine interessante Größe. Wir bewegen uns an sich so schnell, das heißt, wiederum, wir sind ja irgendwie nicht an der maximal möglichen Zeit ausgesetzt.
Ich habe es, 370 Kilometer pro Sekunde bewegen wir uns. Relativ zu dieser kosmischen Suppe.
370 Kilometer pro Sekunde.
Ja, und 300.000 Kilometer pro Sekunde sind die Lichtgeschwindigkeiten. Also ein Tausendstück der Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Okay, ein Promille. Okay, das heißt, wir sind sozusagen, die Zeit vergeht für uns etwas?
Für uns vergeht eine, dauert eine Sekunde, eine Sekunde. Aber für jemanden, der mit der kosmischen Suppe mitschwimmt, der würde sagen, unsere Zeit, also überlegens eine Tausendstück Lichtgeschwindigkeit, das muss man ins Quadrat nehmen, ist eine Million, also um einen Millionstück langsamer. Das ist nicht viel.
Aber ihr könnt im Prinzip mit Fug und Recht behaupten, unsere Uhr geht nach.
Langsamer, ja.
Justiert auch mal eure Zeit. So, das war jetzt Einsteins These mit der speziellen Relativitätstheorie. Warum, was ist jetzt die Relativität? Genau, also relativ ist was?
Relativ ist meine Messung von Längen und Zeiten. Die hängt, die ist relativ zu einem Bewegungszustand. Das ist relativ.
Und wie wurde das Paper so aufgenommen?
Das war in Smashit. Also insbesondere als dieses Marcus & Morley-Experiment dann auch dazu kam. Genau. Und in dieses Geschäft gehört auch diese berühmte Einstein-Formel mit dem E gleich am C-Quadrat. Also das melkt man da auch noch raus.
Energie gleich?
Masse mal Geschwindigkeitsquadrat.
Das heißt, seine Feststellung war, dass es einen Zusammenhang gibt aus Geschwindigkeit?
Ja, die Geschwindigkeit ist da das Unwichtigste an dem Ganzen. Also wir rechnen zum Beispiel immer so, dass wir ein Einheitensystem benutzen. Wir rechnen nicht in Metern und Sekunden, weil das unpraktisch ist, dass einfach die Lichtgeschwindigkeit eins ist. Dann lautet diese Frage einfach E gleich M. Das ist dann nicht mehr so spektakulär.
Energie ist Masse.
Aber die wesentliche Aussage ist, dass Energie und Masse im Wesentlichen das Gleiche sind. Und vergiss das C-Quadrat, das ist nur, um die Einheiten zurechtzubasteln.
Na okay, gut, also Energie ist Masse. Das war sozusagen seine Feststellung. Und was hat das alles so umgeworfen?
Na ja, das ändert zum Beispiel die Sache, dass Masse nicht mehr konstant ist. Also bis dahin, also auch wenn ich Chemie gemacht habe, irgendwelche Sachen verbrannt habe und tolle Reaktionen von Rot geht es nach Grün und so gemacht habe. Wenn ich wirklich aufgepasst habe, dass mir nichts entfleucht ist, also nicht irgendwelche Gase weggedampft sind und ich alles eingefangen habe, dann hat sich die Masse bis dahin nie geändert. Also ich habe vorher ein Kilo Zeug gehabt, dann sind da tolle Dinge drin passiert, hatte ich danach immer noch ein Kilo Zeug.
Nur in einem anderen Zustand?
Nur in einem anderen Zustand. Und das hörte halt erst damit auf, dass man gesehen hat, dass die Masse im Prinzip vom Energiezustand abhängt. Das heißt, wenn ich irgendwie mehr Energie da reintue, dann wirkt sich das genauso aus wie Masse.
Das heißt, wenn ich es erwärme, ändert sich die Masse?
Ja, aber da kommt jetzt doch, wenn man den Zahlenwert irgendwie betrachtet davon, dann ist halt auch dieses C-Quadrat dabei. Und dann stellst du fest, dass das, also mit deiner Küchenwaage wirst du das nicht feststellen, dass du es wenn es ein bisschen wärmer macht. Also das wird erst sozusagen relevant, wenn man irgendwie Kernspaltung macht.
Ja.
Da kommt wirklich, da wird wirklich ernsthaft Masse in Energie umgesetzt.
Wie weit war denn so dieses Verständnis von Atomen und Teilchen bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt gereift? Und inwieweit spielt dir das dann eine Rolle?
Zu dem Zeitpunkt war das halt mit diesen Spektrallinien gerade in Klärung. Und was man auch schon wusste, ist, dass irgendwie die Atome offenbar bestehen aus Elektronen, aus negativ geladenen Teilen.
Also man wusste auf jeden Fall, dass es Atome gibt. Hat man schon welche gesehen.
Also das hängt von deiner Definition von Sehen ab. Also im Prinzip, wenn man diese Linien sieht, könnte man sagen, man sieht die Atome, weil das ein atomarer Effekt ist.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, irgendwann muss man ja zu dieser Erkenntnis gekommen sein, dass die Dinge in kleinen Stücken vorliegen. Genau.
Das hatten schon die Griechen die Idee, dass das vielleicht so ist. Dass man, wenn man halt eine Schokolade hat, die immer weiter teilt, dass sie irgendwann aufhört, Schokolade zu sein. Das folgt im Prinzip auch schon aus Chemie. Dadurch, dass ich feststelle, dass, wenn ich in irgendwelche chemischen Reaktionen mache, dass das besonders gut geht, wenn die Mischungsverhältnisse irgendwie die richtigen sind. Dass ich immer irgendwie die gleiche Menge Sauerstoff und Wasserstoff zusammenbringe, um Wasser zu erzeugen. Das muss immer richtig gemessen im Verhältnis 2 zu 1, 1 zu 1, H2O. Das erklärt sich halt schon am besten aus so einem atomistischen Weltbild. Aber wie diese Atome funktionieren, das wurde auch zu der Zeit klar. Also es gibt einen Atomkern, der enthält im Wesentlichen die Masse des Atoms, also 99,9 Prozent. Und um den herum bewegen sich die Elektronen, die viel leichter sind, halt nur irgendwie 1.800-Tel typischerweise der Masse haben. Und die sind geladen, aber die machen das eigentliche Volumen aus. Der Kern ist viel kleiner als das ganze Atom. Und das ganze Atom wird im Wesentlichen ausgemacht von der Wolke von den Elektronen, die da drum rumfliegen. Das hat der Herr Rutherford festgestellt, indem er geguckt hat, wie radioaktive Teilchen von Atomen gestreut werden. Und er hat halt gesehen, dass die im Wesentlichen so gestreut werden, als gäbe es da positive, positiv geladene Dinge.
Das heißt, man hatte schon eine Vorstellung, also Atome waren irgendwie klar, und man hatte auch schon etwa eine Vorstellung davon, dass die aus Kernen bestehen, um die irgendwelche Dinge herumfliegen und dass auch wahrscheinlich diese Elektronenwolke im Wesentlichen dafür verantwortlich ist, ob das eine sich mit dem anderen in irgendeiner Form zusammenbringen lässt.
Genau, also dass die Chemie durch Strom zusammenhängt. Genau.
Also also auch Strom hat man sozusagen schon auf diese Elektronen zurückgeführt.
Ja, also das ist eigentlich nur die Aussage, dass die geladen sind schon.
Ja, was ist dann passiert, als Einstein so ketzerisch da das mit der Zeit?
Naja, das war auch schon ein, also das war nicht nur eine Sache, die irgendwie von interessierten Fachkreisen wahrgenommen wurde, sondern das ist auch durch die populäre Presse gegangen. Also dieses Slogan mit alles ist relativ und eh gleich MC. Und dazu kommt, dass das halt so ein Typ ist mit irgendwie, dem die Haare in alle Richtungen stehen und der sich unkonventionell kleidet und sich auch mit Zunge rausfotografieren lässt und so.
Der totale Punk eigentlich. Aber das Wissen der Öffentlichkeit dürfte ja sehr eingeschränkt gewesen sein. Wie ist denn das sozusagen, also was war denn da sozusagen die eigentliche Botschaft da drin, dass alle da so drauf abgegangen sind? Ich meine normalerweise...
Na, dieses alles ist relativ, passt halt auch politisch irgendwie in so ein...
Na gut, aber das hat dann gleich schon so ein Pop ausgelöst. War das sozusagen alles, was die Öffentlichkeit wahrgenommen hat?
Ja, und eben E-gleich-MC ist irgendwie begriffig. Hat jeder schon mal gesehen.
Aber was konnte denn so der gemeine Bürger aus dieser Formel für sich ableiten? Da war eigentlich gar nichts.
Nee. Aber das ist ja bei Pop häufig so.
Er war einfach so Popstar, weil bei ihm das einfach gepasst hat. Man hat gemerkt, irgendwie der wissenschaftliche Prozess ist irgendwie komplett durcheinander geraten.
Der Typ war halt auch clever. Also das muss man halt auch sagen. Also der hat halt nicht nur das gemacht, sondern der hat in diesem 1905-Jahr dem Anus Mirabilis, bin kein Altsprachler, hat er irgendwie vier dolle Dinger, vier Veröffentlichungen geschrieben, die alle irgendwie ground-breaking waren. Und für die eine hat er auch einen Nobelpreis gekriegt. Interessanterweise nie einen Nobelpreis für die Relativitätstheorie gekriegt.
Hätte er aber eigentlich verdient gehabt.
Ja, da ranken sich tolle Verschwörungstheorien darum. So, aber wir müssen ein bisschen vorankommen, glaube ich.
Ja, aber ich finde das auch mal ganz wichtig, dass man so die kleinen Schritte geht.
Aber eine weitere Folgerung daraus ist eben, dass die Lichtgeschwindigkeit die maximale Geschwindigkeit ist. Dass man irgendwie nichts schneller, keine Nachrichten auch schneller austauschen kann als mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Das folgt aus dieser Variabilität von Raum und Zeit, weil wenn man irgendwie eine Nachricht schneller als mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit schicken könnte, kann man sich einen anderen Beobachter denken, der sich irgendwie passend mit einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit dazu bewegt, zu diesem Nachrichtenaustausch. Und für den würde sagen dann die Formeln vorher, dass für den die Nachricht rückwärts in der Zeit geschickt wird. Du rollst mit den Augen.
Naja, Nachricht, also das ist ja schon so wirklich so in informationstechnischem Angriff.
Ja, aber so ist das auch gemeint. Und also wenn ich es schaffe, irgendwie ein Teilchen oder eine Nachricht oder irgendwas, also wenn ich, ich kann ja meine Nachricht auch mit einer Flaschenpost schicken, oder ich schicke irgendwie ein Teilchen irgendwie. Meine Nachricht ist, ob ich ein Teilchen schicke oder nicht. Wenn ich das schneller als mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit schicken könnte, dann sagt die Relativitätstheorie vorher, dass es dann theoretisch einen Beobachter geben könnte, dass der Ankunftszeitpunkt der Nachricht vor dem Aussendungszeitpunkt liegt.
Time.
Die Folge davon ist, weil das halt absurd ist und nicht geht, ist die erste Annahme, dass man schneller als mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit kommunizieren kann.
Okay, aber ich dachte, Maxwell hat nur gesagt, es gibt eine Lichtgeschwindigkeit und sie ist konstant im Vakuum. Dann war die große Frage, geht es schneller?
Geht schneller und geht halt nicht.
Das folgte sozusagen aus Einsteinsbetrachtung heraus. Ah ja, man kann nicht. Aber die Zeit, ich meine, damit wankte dann ja sozusagen auch überhaupt generell diese Vorstellung von Zeit.
Ja, es gab halt nicht mehr die eine Zeit.
Aber es ist dann nicht sozusagen auch vorstellbar gewesen, dass man dann in dieser Zeit auch zurück kann oder geht Zeit schon irgendwie? Oder ist das halt das, was nicht geht? Man kann nicht zurück.
Das ist halt einfach eine Beobachtung. Das wüsstest du sofort. Weil dann würden halt alle Lotterien kein Business-Modell mehr haben.
Du meinst, wenn das möglich wäre, dann müsste es ja zwangsläufig auch schon stattgefunden haben, weil... Okay, ja, da ist was dran. Das heißt, man kann davon ausgehen, es gibt aber eigentlich auch nur einen Zeitpunkt. Dieses gesamte Universum befindet sich zu... also jetzt in einem Gesamtzustand. Relativ sind nur die ganzen Beobachtungen dahinein.
Nein, dazu gehört auch, dass der Zeitpunkt fest zu dem Ort gehört. Also ich kann sagen, jetzt und hier bin ich. Aber wenn ich einen anderen Ort habe, der hat auch möglicherweise irgendeinen Zeitpunkt, dann kann es sein, dass wenn der Ort so weit weg ist, nämlich so weit, dass Ort und Zeit heißt zusammen Ereignis, also dieses Package aus Ort und Zeit, und wenn zwei Ereignisse so weit getrennt sind, dass wenn ich zwischen ihnen hin und her kommen wollte, ich mit mehr Lichtgeschwindigkeit mich bewegen müsste, dann macht es eben nicht mehr Sinn zu sagen, welches vorher und welches später ist, weil das vom Betrachter abhängt. Und deswegen gehört, die Zeit gehört zu einem bestimmten Ort dazu. Und es ist erstmal nicht offensichtlich, wie zu sagen, die gleiche Zeit an einem anderen Ort. Das hängt auch vom Betrachter ab.
Wie ist denn das jetzt hier, ist das jetzt auch nur so ein Märchen, aber so der Astronaut, der in Höchstgeschwindigkeit um diesen Planeten rumgeht, der bewegt sich ja nun definitiv sehr viel schneller als ich.
Genau.
Welche Auswirkungen hat denn das jetzt auf die Zeit, wenn der da irgendwie hochgeht?
Denen vergeht sie langsamer und dann ist das, also das macht man ja am besten mit Zwillingen, damit man das irgendwie schon vergleichen kann. Der eine Astronaut, der eine ist Astronaut und der andere ist irgendwie im Kontrollzentrum geblieben und der Astronaut zurückkommt, ist der andere schon viel weiter gealtert, weil für den, der rumgeflogen ist, die Zeit...
Ist das eine messbare Zeit? Also was ist so...
Also bei Astronauten...
Wenn ich jetzt so ein Jahr lang im All rumkurve?
Nicht bei den Geschwindigkeiten, bei denen da geflogen wird. Also mit Astronauten misst man das nicht. Man kann das aber messen, wenn du eine Atomuhr... Das haben Leute gemacht, haben eine Atomuhr ins Flugzeug geladen und sind damit irgendwie... Weiß nicht so lange, bis der Treibstoff wie der Treibstoff gehalten hat, mit dem Jet durch die Gegend geflogen und haben das mit einer Atomuhr, die sie zu Hause gelassen haben, verglichen. Und dann misst man den erwarteten Zeitunterschied.
Der so in welchem Bereich lag dann?
Jetzt müssen wir wieder rechnen. Also was fliegt so ein Jet, 1000 kmh ungefähr? Wenn es gut kommt. Es ist zu früh am Morgen.
Aber sehr kleine.
Man braucht schon eine sehr genaue Uhr. Aber bei anderen Sachen, wo man das viel mehr sehen kann, es gibt zum Beispiel andere Teilchen, die sogenannten Myonen, die sind das gleiche Teilchen wie Elektronen, die sind nur wesentlich schwerer. Aber die kommen aus der kosmischen Höhenstrahlung auf die Erde. Wenn man einen entsprechenden Detektor auf den Tisch stellt, der ist auch so, den kann man auf den Tisch stellen, dann sieht man die. Die machen einen Großteil der Höhenstrahlung aus.
Die fliegen hier durch alles durch?
Die fliegen 100 Stück durch jeden Quadratmeter pro Sekunde. Aber weil die schwerer sind, als die Elektronen zerfallen, die radioaktiv in sehr kurzer Zeit in Elektronen. Und in einer so kurzen Zeit, die werden am oberen Ende der Atmosphäre erzeugt, dadurch, dass da andere Teilchen kollidieren mit der Atmosphäre. Und die dürften es eigentlich nicht bis an die Oberfläche der Erde schaffen, weil deren Lebensdauer zu kurz ist. Die fliegen dann auch noch fast mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit, aber selbst da dauert die Zeit zu lange für deren Lebenszeit. Aber die fliegen halt so schnell, dass ihre Zeit so viel langsamer läuft, dass auch der radioaktive Zerfall entsprechend langsamer läuft.
Schauen sie es bis auf die Erde, obwohl eigentlich ihre Halbwertzeit nicht ausreicht.
Genau, aber es ist halt nur die Halbwertzeit in Ruhe. Und die bewegte Halbwertzeit ist entsprechend länger, und da macht dieser Faktor viel aus.
Das heißt, wenn ich nochmal diesen Uhrenvergleich herbeihole, die eine Uhr läuft langsamer, das bedeutet, dass sozusagen in der schnellen Bewegung, in der man sich befindet, in diesem Jet, läuft die Zeit langsamer. Das heißt, dieses ganze Gewirke von Elektronen, Strom, alles befindet sich in so einem Trägheitszustand dadurch. Aber warum?
Du kannst es selbst nicht fest... Also es ist nicht so, dass... Also es ist nicht dieses, wenn ich in einem langweiligen Meeting sitze, geht die Zeit langsamer. Das ist ein anderer Effekt. Sondern das merkt man nicht, weil es vergeht für jeden... Es vergeht die Zeit gleich schnell. Es ist nicht so, dass ich auf die Uhr gucke und der Zeiger tickt langsamer.
Weil auch meine Wahrnehmung kürtet ja genauso im gleichen Maße.
Also insofern, man merkt es nicht, sondern man merkt es nur im Vergleich. Und deswegen ist es auch nicht so, dass man sich irgendwie zäher bewegt oder so, sondern man bewegt sich so wie immer. Man merkt ja nichts davon. Und das mit den Zwillingen und der eine fliegt, scheint ja deswegen noch paradox zu sein, weil man sich auch in die Perspektive des Astronauten versetzen kann, der auch für sich sagt, ich sitze in meiner Rakete und es fliegt irgendwie die Erde rund um die Rakete rum, dann müsste doch bei dem anderen die Zeit langsam in Vergangenheit sein. Weil ich bin ja in Ruhe und der hat sich relativ zu mir bewegt. Also müsste der andere ja irgendwie jünger sein als ich. Aber das kann ich objektiv feststellen, wenn die zusammenkommen, welcher von denen irgendwie schrumpelig ist und wer noch die dunklen Haare hat und noch nicht ergraut ist. Und das wird aufgelöst, dadurch, dass die Situation nicht symmetrisch ist, weil der eine beschleunigt worden ist. Also der eine bleibt in Ruhe sitzen und der Astronaut wird halt am Anfang einmal auf die Geschwindigkeit beschleunigt und am Ende wieder abgebremst. Und das kann ich auch objektiv feststellen, ob ich beschleunigt werde oder abgebremst werde. Und deswegen ist die Situation nicht symmetrisch und der eine ist wirklich langsam geworden. Und das bringt uns jetzt auch schon zehn Jahre weiter zu einem sehr großem Ananwurf, nämlich der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie, wo er sich einerseits zur Ruhe Sorgen gemacht hat, dass dieses Newtonische Gravitationsgesetz nicht zusammenpasst mit der speziellen Relativitätstheorie. Weil diese Gravitationskraft, die zum Beispiel die Sonne auf die Erde ausübt oder die Erde auf den Apfel, der runterfällt, ausübt, die wird ja sofort übertragen. Ja, also in der Newtonischen Theorie, da, wo die Sonne jetzt ist, von da aus übt sie die Anziehungskraft auf die Erde aus.
Aber dann müsste sie sicher etwas schneller als die Lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen.
Jetzt könnte man einfach die Sonne nehmen und an der Sonne hin und her rütteln. Und dann würde man bei der Erde sofort merken, dass da irgendwie gewackelt wird. Und das kann ja nicht sein. Also kann das mit dieser Newtonischen Theorie nicht der Weisheit letzter Schluss gewesen sein.
Mit anderen Worten, auch diese Gravitationsenergie bewegt sich bestenfalls in Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Ja, genau. Also wir sollten das Kraft nennen, nicht Energie, aber...
Okay, Gravitationskraft.
Genau. Und nun muss ich halt eine Theorie...
In welche Richtung bewegt sich da eigentlich was?
Genau. Also da muss ich halt jetzt... Das hat Einstein, der nun wirklich clever war, zehn Jahre seines Lebens gekostet, das sich genau auszuarbeiten, wie man das denn nun irgendwie, wie man die Newton-Schritt-Theorie so modifizieren kann, dass sie kompatibel wird mit dieser speziellen Relativitätstheorie. Und das hat ihn auf die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie geführt. Und da macht man halt jetzt dieses ganze Fass mit Raumkrümmung und so weiter auf. Das ist die Lösung dazu.
Dann machen wir das Fass mal auf.
Machen wir das Fass auf. Also, da fängt es halt an, da kann man jetzt nochmal auf deine ursprüngliche Frage, was steckt denn hinter der Gravitation und dahinter zurückkommen. Da ist halt die Erkenntnis, also die erste Erkenntnis, es gibt ja ein Relativitätsprinzip. Also das erste Relativitätsprinzip war, bei der speziellen Relativitätstheorie, ich kann nicht feststellen, ob ich mich bewege oder nicht bewege, insbesondere nicht dadurch, dass ich die Lichtgeschwindigkeit messe. Und das neue Relativitätsprinzip ist, ich kann nicht feststellen, wenn ich lokal bin, ob ich Gravitation spüre oder ob ich Beschleunigung spüre. Und wenn ich in der Rakete bin und die beschleunigt, dann fühlt sich das einfach genauso an, als ob da irgendwie Gravitationskraft wirkt. Und es ist auch das Gleiche, man kann es nicht auseinanderhalten. Und diesen Gedankengang ins Extrem getrieben bringt einen dazu, festzustellen, dass das, was uns wie Gravitation erscheint, in Wahrheit eine Krümmung von dieser Raumzeit, wo diese Events oder diese Ereignisse, diese Packages aus einem Ort und einem Zeitpunkt leben, dass dieses kein flacher vierdimensionaler Raum ist, sondern ein gekrümmter vierdimensionaler Raum.
Raumzeit. Da kommt jetzt sozusagen, also dieses Zeit ist relativ zu dem Ort und vor allem davon abhängig, wie schnell er sich bewegt im Verhältnis zu anderen.
Genau.
Für sich genommen ist es immer irgendwie dasselbe Spiel, aber zwei Orte im Raum haben jeweils ihre eigene Zeit und sie kann unterschiedlich schnell laufen.
Und auch der Raum muss halt, die Raumkoordinaten können halt jetzt auch noch, müssen halt nicht ein kathesisches Koordinatensystem, wo überall rechte Winkel sind.
Ja, so wie man sich das vorher vorgestellt hat, einfach so sein Raum in 3D und dann gibt es irgendwie X, Y und Z und das war's.
Und X, Y und Z gehen von minusinendlich bis unendlich theoretisch.
Das war so die klassische Annahme. Und seine Annahme war jetzt, das ist alles gar nicht, sondern der Raum ist in sich verzerrt. Das heißt, es gibt da Verdichtungen und es gibt irgendwie Streckungen? Oder was heißt diese Krümmung?
Also ein etwas gefährliches Bild, aber was eigentlich ganz gut ist, also woran merkt man diese Krümmung? Man steht ja nicht außerhalb dieses Raums und kann da irgendwie draufgucken, sondern wir sind da irgendwie drin und das muss, wir müssen eine intrinsische Beschreibung dafür finden. Das vorweggesagt. Aber zum Beispiel das Paradebeispiel für eine gekrümmte Oberfläche ist eine Kugeloberfläche. Und zwar nur die Oberfläche davon. Wir nehmen uns jetzt nur die Oberfläche. Und im flachen Raum, also im normalen, so wenn man irgendwie Geometrie mit Zirkel und Lineal und Geodreieck macht, dann ist ja eine dieser Regeln, die man hat, dass wenn ich zwei Parallele, dass ich, wenn ich zwei Graden habe, dann schneiden die sich entweder irgendwo genau einmal oder sie sind parallel, dann schneiden sie sich nirgendwo. Und wenn ich eine Gerade habe und einen Punkt, dann gibt es genau eine Parallele gerade durch diesen Punkt, also der Punkt liegt nicht auf der ersten Grade, sondern so, dass die parallel sind. Das ist das parallelen Axiom. So, nun versuche ich das gleich auf einer Kugelloberfläche zu machen. Was heißt da gerade? Da stellt sich raus, dass die richtige Verallgemeinerung von gerade ist etwas, was lokal nicht um die Kurve geht. Und auf einer Kugel ist das ein Großkreis. Also so wie der Äquator, also ein Kreis auf der Kugelloberfläche, der halt den maximalen, also wo der Zentrum des Kreises der Zentrum der Kugelmittelpunkt ist. Das ist die entsprechende, der Entsprechung zu einer zu einer Graden auf der Oberfläche. Und jetzt nehme ich zwei, zwei solche Großkreise und dann weiß ich, die schneiden sich immer zweimal an den Antipoden.
Wenn sie die gleiche Länge haben.
Die haben alle die gleiche Länge, weil sind alle maximale Kreise auf einer Kugeloberfläche. Also wenn sie nicht der gleiche Kreis sind, wie Mathematiker, die spitzwendig sind, wenn sie verschieden sind, dann gibt es immer zwei Schnittpunkte und diese liegen immer gegenüber. Und auf der Kugeloberfläche verhalten sich also die Graden nicht so wie die Graden in der Ebene. Weil in der Ebene gibt es halt parallele Graden, die schneiden sich gar nicht und alle anderen Graden schneiden sich genau einmal. Und auf der Kugeloberfläche schneiden sich halt die Dinge, die analoger zu Graden sind, immer zweimal.
Immer. Das heißt, das ist ein Beispiel für eine Krümel?
Gekrömmte Oberfläche. Da gelten halt diese normalen Geometrieriegeln.
Wie kann man das jetzt auf den dreidimensionalen Raum erweitern, wenn er dreidimensional ist?
Im Prinzip auch so. Also eine andere Konsequenz ist, dass die Summe der Winkel in einem Dreieck in der Ebene immer 180 Grad ist. Das ist im Krümmenraum nicht mehr so.
Jetzt gibt es auch da dieses Bild von Kugeln, die in Tüchern liegen und diese Krümmung ausdrücken.
Was das Wesentliche an diesem Bild ist, ist das Tuch. Vergiss die Kugel. Die sollen nur irgendwie deutlich machen, sozusagen eine Erklärung, warum dieses Tuch da so eine Delle hat. Das Wesentliche ist, die Kugel ist da nicht mehr relevant. Jetzt guckt man sich nur dieses gekrümmte Tuch an.
Also wir haben jetzt so ein Gummituch irgendwie.
Genau, und da liegt was drin und deswegen geht es da so ein bisschen nach unten. Und wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, was auf der Fläche des Gummituchs die Entsprechung von einer gerade ist, nämlich etwas, was lokal immer gerade ausgeht. Wenn ich zum Beispiel kurzsichtig bin und darauf rumlaufe und irgendwie nicht ein kürzeres Bein habe und deswegen irgendwie schaffe, gerade auszulaufen, dann würde ich halt in der Ebene immer auf einer gerade laufen. Und dann auf der Kugel würde ich halt auf diesem Großkreis laufen. Und auf dem Gummituch würde ich halt auf einer komplizierteren Bahn laufen. Und insbesondere gibt es da Bahnen, sodass ich da auch im Kreis laufe, nämlich einmal um diese Senke, die ich produziert habe drumrum. Und das ist das Bild eben für die Planeten. Die Planeten machen auch nichts weiter. Die fallen auch sozusagen immer nur geradeaus durch die Raumzeit. Aber dieses geradeaus, nämlich lokal geradeaus, ist im großen, in der großen gekrümmten Raumzeit gesehen die Bahn, die sie, die Ellipsenbahn, die sie um die Sonne machen. Das ist eine Geradeausbahn, auch wenn es für uns nicht so aussieht.
Okay, das heißt, dieser Ellipsenweg, dieser Weg um die Sonne herum, den die Erde beschreitet, auf dem wir uns die ganze Zeit befinden, ist für uns eigentlich ein permanentes Geradeaus. Wir fliegen immer gerade.
Genau.
Aber es ergibt sich deswegen eine Kreisbahn, weil die Sonne den Raum krümmt.
Also das Wichtigste, damit es wirklich richtig wird, ist die Raumzeit. Man muss die Zeit dazu nehmen.
Okay, die Raumzeit.
Das ist schwer vorzustellen, aber sonst wird es leider falsch.
Okay, gut, das verstehe ich jetzt noch nicht so ganz genau, was das jetzt aussagt, aber gehen wir jetzt erst mal von diesem Ort aus, wie auch immer man ihn jetzt nennt. Und die Sonne ist da und schier mit ihrem Dasein, also mit ihrer Masse, kann man das sagen?
Genau, die Masse verursacht das.
Also dadurch, dass das Ding einfach so schwer und so groß ist, wirkt sie auf diesen Raum und schafft sozusagen so eine Senke. Das heißt, dass mein geradeaus-Weg ist eigentlich gar nicht ein geradeaus auf einer geraden Fläche, sondern tatsächlich befinde ich mich eher so an so einem Rand von so einem Loch und fliege da und rolle da sozusagen die ganze Zeit im Kreis, auch wenn es mir irgendwie anders vorkommt.
Genau, und so ist es ja auch, wenn ich irgendeinen Satelliten zum Beispiel habe, also Satelliten haben ja häufiger die, die um die Erde fliegen, dann fliegen die auch genauer auf so einer Bahn. Die Erde macht das auch eben für die Satelliten. Und die Satelliten fliegen natürlich auch irgendwie auf einer Kreis- oder einer Ellipsenbahn um die Erde. Aber wenn ich auf dem Satelliten bin oder im Space Shuttle oder in der International Space Station, dann fühle ich ja nicht die ganze Zeit eine Zentrifugalkraft, die mich da irgendwie auf diese Kreisbahn zwingt, sondern da fühle ich einen freien Fall. Und dieser freie Fall ist genau diese gerade Ausbewegung.
Das heißt, das ist dann die Gravitation. Das heißt, die Gravitation ist dann eben nicht, wie man hätte noch am Anfang denken können, so eine Kraft, die in Überlichtgeschwindigkeit sich auf alles gleichzeitig auswirkt, sondern die Gravitation ist einfach sozusagen schon da, dadurch, dass irgendwo eine Masse herumliegt und der ganze Raum oder Raumzeit sackt irgendwie ab und verändert sich quasi permanent durch diese Präsenz. Aber auch diese Auswirkung muss ja irgendwie dann auch mal stattfinden, zwangsläufig in Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Nein, also eine Sache muss ich noch leider verkomplizieren.
Ja, bitte.
Dieses Senken gibt ja eine Vorstellung, also das ist dieses Bild von dieser Membran oder von diesem Gummituch. Diese Richtung, in die sich das senkt, die gibt es natürlich nicht, weil wir haben schon alle Richtungen aufgebraucht. Deswegen ist das ein bisschen gefährlich, so zu denken. Und das andere ist, dass diese Information, also wo halt Masse ist und wie das sich auswirkt auf die Raumzeitkrümmung, das breitet sich auch nur mit Wellen aus. Das breitet sich auch mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Genau, aber es ändert sich ja nicht permanent, sondern diese Masse...
Nein, aber wenn ich an der Sonne tatsächlich irgendwie anfange rumzuwackeln, dann diese Information darüber, wo die Sonne sich befindet und in welche Richtung die Anziehungskraft gefälligst zu laufen hat, diese Information breitet sich auch mit einer Wellen, also das sind Füktationen von dieser Raumzeit und die laufen so wellenförmig dann über das Gummituch weg.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie einen Mechanismus hätte, also angenommen, ich bin da so in der Lage, mit so einem riesigen Sonnen-Eiskugelschäler aus der Sonne dann einfach mal so ein dickes Teil rauszunehmen und so in Nullzeit wegzuteleportieren, ich würde sozusagen die Masse der Sonne schlagartig reduzieren. Ich kann das nicht, aber...
Nein, du kannst sie nicht, aber du könntest sie anschieben. Du könntest irgendwie einen Raketenmotor an die Sonne bauen und so zünden und dann schieben wir die Sonne mal so ein Stück zur Seite.
Und dann? Ach so, dann müsste sich das ja auch entsprechen. Aber dann würde das sozusagen Lichtgeschwindigkeit, also mit der Trägheit der Lichtgeschwindigkeit, also Lichtgeschwindigkeit mit Trägheit zu reden, ist lustig, aber das ist es ja im Prinzip, weil das ist kein Sofort, sondern es dauert dann halt eine Weile, bis diese Auswirkung auch wirklich ankommt. Aber sie ist dann sozusagen permanent.
Genau.
So lange, bis die Masse sich wieder ändert. So, und das erklärt sozusagen, warum die Gravitation nicht mit Überlichtgeschwindigkeit fliegen muss, vor allem, weil sie es nicht kann, aber das auch nicht muss, weil diese Auswirkung sozusagen eine permanente Auswirkung ist. Und dadurch krümmt sich, ja, ich würde jetzt immer noch sagen, der Raum. Warum muss ich denn Raumzeit sagen? Warum ist das denn falsch? Das ist eine reine Formelfrage.
Also, wenn man guckt die Bahn, also der Raum ist im Sonnensystem im Wesentlichen noch flach, weil die Gravitation sehr schwach ist. Und die Krümmung ist sogar hauptsächlich in dieser Zeitrichtung. Also, das, was die Planeten auf die Bahn zwingt, ist im Wesentlichen die Krümmung in der Zeitrichtung. Aber da muss man ein bisschen Formeln für machen.
Okay, also ich mache jetzt keinen generellen Fehler, wenn ich jetzt einfach Raum denke, aber eigentlich Raumzeit nennen müsste. Gut, so, das heißt, diese Betrachtung von Einstein mit der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie schafft ein Bild dafür, warum die ganzen Sonnensysteme überhaupt so stabil vor sich hin werkeln und die Planeten sich um die Sonne drehen, ohne jetzt im Widerspruch zu stehen gegen den Erkenntnissen seiner eigenen speziellen Relativitätstheorie und mechswischen Gleichen und diesem ganzen anderen Kram.
Außer, dass im Prinzip die Stabilität dieser Planeten-Systeme, also der Unterschied auf dem Level von Planeten-Systemen zwischen dieser alten Newton-Theorie und der einsteinischen Theorie ist minimal. Also, die Newton-Theorie ist vollkommen hinreichend, um irgendwie alle Planetenbewegungen zu beschreiben.
Aber es hat bloß nicht erklärt, wie diese Kraft wirkt.
Genau, und es war halt nicht konsistent mit dieser speziellen Relativitätstheorie, die man hat auch.
Und Einstein hat dann sozusagen das genauer beschrieben, aber daraus ergeht dann sozusagen, dass eben dieser ganze Raum verzerrt ist.
Genau. Und dann kann man das natürlich, wenn man einmal sowas hat, dann treibt man das natürlich immer wieder bis zum Extrem. Das ist halt unser Geschäft. Dass man irgendwie darüber nachdenkt, okay, so ist das, was bedeutet das dann? Und in diesem Fall wäre das halt so, dass kann ich ja gucken, was passiert denn, wenn die Gravitation immer stärker wird. Also zum Beispiel, wenn die Sonne nicht so groß wäre, sondern halt wesentlich kleiner wäre. Und es ist ja so, die Gravitation wird ja immer stärker, je dichter ich rangehe. Und zwar ran an das Zentrum. Und bei der Sonne endet das halt irgendwo, weil man dann irgendwie an die Oberfläche der Sonne kommt. Aber wenn sie kleiner wäre, dann könnte man halt noch dichter an ihr Zentrum rankommen. Und wenn sie halt nur ungefähr zehn Kilometer groß wäre, dann wäre da halt die Gravitation so stark, dass selbst das Licht nicht mehr wegkommt. Dann wäre es ja ein schwarzes Loch. Das ist die Konsequenz davon, dass es eben diese schwarzen Löcher gibt, dass diese Raumzeitkrümmung so stark sein kann, dass selbst das Licht nicht mehr schnell genug ist, dem zu entkommen.
Das muss ja in einem Planeten dann sozusagen eigentlich immer der Fall sein, oder?
Nee, ich muss schon die gesamte Masse halt so dicht zusammenbringen.
Und gibt es irgendwie eine gute Erklärung davon, warum diese Masse diese Kraft überhaupt so entfaltet?
Nicht mehr, als dass sie eben die Raumkrümmung auslöst.
Okay, das heißt, man weiß es einfach, aber so richtig vorstellen kann man sich das eigentlich auch noch nicht, warum das so ist.
Ja, also warum ist so eine schwierige Frage.
Na ja, dafür bin ich schon da hier.
Nein, nein, also was meint man mit warum? Also sobald man sich davon verabschiedet, dass der liebe Gott so alles gut für uns eingerichtet hat.
Also das, warum meint man das, ja. Ich meinte jetzt nicht so, was ist der Sinn davon, dass es das tut, sondern was ist sozusagen. Also es ist natürlich sehr schwierig, sich dieses Wechselspiel vorzustellen. Klar, ich habe jetzt da irgendwie so Atome, und die häufen sich und ergeben sozusagen eine große Masse. Und das hat dann irgendwie enorme Auswirkungen auf Dinge, die doch relativ weit weg sind. Das muss man sich ja auch erstmal klar machen. Na gut, wir wollen ja auch eigentlich noch sehr viel weiter hier im Gespräch. Ich fand das jetzt mal ganz spannend, auch mal so ein bisschen die Grundlagen nochmal zu vergegenwärtigen. Weil das sind auch immer so Sachen, die man dann, glaube ich, auch gerade als Wissenschaftler immer so als selbstverständlich, ja. Das weiß man ja seit dem Einstein.
Haben wir nicht alle PM gelesen?
Aber auch das war irgendwie auch immer so alles ein bisschen verwandt. Ja, da war das Gefühl, alle zehn Jahre ändert sich halt der Blick auf diese ganze Geschichte sowieso nochmal komplett. Da ist ja auch schwierig, da irgendwie abtönt wird, zu bleiben. So, jetzt bin ich mir gerade so ein bisschen unklar, was man denn sozusagen als nächstes da eigentlich jetzt entgehen muss. Die eigentliche Frage ist natürlich dann immer die, woher kommt denn dieser ganze Scheiß? Ich meine, wir wissen ja irgendwie, okay, überall sind jetzt Sonnen und irgendwie wir wissen jetzt auch, warum sie irgendwie so umeinander herumkreisen und was sie so für Kräfte aufeinander auslösen und mit welcher Geschwindigkeit da so maximal kommuniziert werden kann und dass die Zeit relativ ist und so. Okay, das haben wir jetzt irgendwie alles gefressen. Das ist aber jetzt sozusagen alles nur eine Erklärung des Ist-Zustandes. Das ist ja schon mal ganz gut, dass man den so halbwegs erfasst hat. Oder fehlt da jetzt eigentlich in der Betrachtung noch irgendeine nennenswerte Wahrnehmung? Das ist im Wesentlichen sozusagen. So, und dann stellt sich natürlich die nächste Frage ja, okay, alles klar. Und wo kommt das jetzt alles bitte her? Wo ist bitte der große kosmologische Bergbau, wo man diese ganzen Atome überhaupt hergeholt hat?
Genau, also da gibt es halt auch wieder im Wesentlichen zwei Möglichkeiten. Also die eine total banale Antwort wäre, das war schon immer so. Und das wäre sozusagen die Fortsetzung in der Zeit von dem im Raum, warum soll es nicht immer weitergehen? Also das ist, wenn ich feststelle, das ist in alle Richtungen irgendwie gleich, dann und ich auch irgendwie weiß, dass sich Raum und Zeit irgendwie ähnlich verhalten, dann kann man ja auch sagen, das war schon immer so. Also da, aber wir hatten ja vorhin schon darüber geredet, dass die Sachen von uns wegfliegen, dass es diese Ausdehnung gibt. Und dass sie halt immer weiter wegfliegen, je weiter man wegguckt.
Was man einfach festgestellt hat durch diese Betrachtung dieses Doppler-Effekts.
Dieses Doppler-Effekt. Und die Schwierigkeit dabei ist unabhängig davon festzustellen, wie weit die Sachen weg sind. Also die Bewegung ist sehr einfach zu beobachten mit dem Doppler-Shift, aber zu sagen, wie weit so ein Stern weg ist oder so eine Galaxie, ist halt beobachtungstechnisch irgendwie nicht so trivial. Aber da brauchen wir vielleicht nicht darauf einzugehen, nur um zu sagen, dass man heute benutzt, man diesen Doppler-Effekt umgekehrt, um die Entfernung zu bestimmen. Also man sieht, wie schnell es wegfliegt, dann sagt man, ja, wir wissen ja, dass alles ungefähr, also je schneller es wegfliegt, desto weiter ist es weg. Und wenn wir sehen, wie schnell es wegfliegt, dann wissen wir, wie weit es weg ist. Aber man kann das ja, wenn es halt von uns wegfliegt, dann kann man auch in der Zeit zurückgucken und kann sich fragen, ja, was passiert denn, wenn es halt alles wegfliegt, dann muss es ja irgendwo hergekommen sein. Muss es von uns irgendwie hergekommen sein, muss es ja erstmal hier gewesen sein. Und das bringt einen halt auf die Idee, dass das nicht schon immer so war, sondern dass es einen Zeitpunkt gab, der nach heute, also nach der, wenn ich da die zahlrichtigen Erinnerungen habe, die beruht eben aus der Vermessung daraus, wie schnell die Sachen wegfliegen, vor 14 Billionen Jahren war, war das halt alles hier. Also da war der ganze Raum halt an einem Punkt zusammen. Also wenn man diese Wegfliegbewegung extra poliert, dann war alles vor 14 Billionen Jahren an einem Punkt.
14 Billionen, also 14.000 Milliarden Jahre.
Ja, ich hoffe, das ist keine amerikanische...
Nee, nee, wir sind hier bei europäischer Maßgebung. Das wäre ein bisschen zu... Nur ein bisschen so, sich vorzustellen, wie viel das ist, das ist ja irgendwie eine ganze Menge.
Genau, und das ist die Idee von diesem Urknall. Also das zurück, dann wieder, dann die Zeit wieder in die Fahrwärtsrichtung gedreht.
Das heißt, es geht davon aus, dass alle Atome, alle diese ganzen Elektronen, Protonen, alles, was irgendwie Masse hat, dass die gesamte Masse sich an einem einzigen Ort befunden hat.
Ja, aber dazu, dass das ganze Universum ein einziger Ort war. Also es ist nicht so, dass es da drum herum alles leer war, sondern es ist ja der Raum, der sich ausdehnt. Und die waren schon alle an ihrem Platz, bloß ihr Platz war halt überall dasselbe.
Aber müssten sie ja nicht so viele enorme Gravitationen gehabt haben, dass sie so zusammenkleben, dass da eigentlich gar nichts raus kann?
Na ja, also wenn man das extra poliert, dann fliegt das halt dann doch in dem Moment sehr schnell auch auseinander. Und wir wissen ja, dass irgendwie Geschwindigkeit gerne mal auch Gravitationen überwinden kann. Also das ist schon, das passt schon zusammen. Also das fliegt halt so schnell auseinander. Und die andere wichtige Sache ist, wenn das halt immer dichter wird...
Das heißt, es fliegt schneller auseinander als das Licht?
Nein, natürlich nicht schneller als das Licht. Aber um die gegenseitige Gravitation zu balancieren. Oder aus oder zu überwinden. Aber was dazu noch kommt, es ist nicht nur so, dass es immer das gleiche war und dichter zusammenkommt. Sondern wenn die Dichte größer wird, dann wird es auch wärmer. Umgekehrt versteht man das vielleicht besser. Wenn etwas sich ausdehnt und voneinander weggeht, dann kühlt sich das Universum ab. Und das heißt, wenn ich in der Zeit zurückgehe, wird es immer wärmer. Und da gibt es dann halt so Punkte, wo es so warm war, dass die Sachen nicht mehr so waren, wie wir sie heute kennen.
Wie muss man sich denn Wärme eigentlich vorstellen jetzt? Was macht denn Wärme aus?
Wärme macht nur aus, dass die Sachen, die inneren Bestandteile sich schnell bewegen.
Das heißt, all diese Elektronen, die sich da irgendwie immer drehen, umso wärmer sie sind, umso schneller drehen sie sich, mal so ganz salopp formuliert?
Im Prinzip ja. Im Prinzip ja. Und die verschiedenen Atome, die in Molekülen zusammengebunden sind, da fangen die Moleküle an zu zittern.
Ein einziges Espenlaub.
Genau. Auf einem formalen Level bedeutet es einfach nur, dass da sehr viel Energie in den ganzen Freiheitsgraden entsteht.
Das Ganze war ein extrem nervöses Gezottel von unfassbar, unvollstellbar großer Masse.
Ja, und die Temperatur geht nach unendlich, wenn man zu diesem Zeitpunkt zurückgeht.
Und das ist jetzt sozusagen der einzige Zustand, der sich ablesen lässt. Den müsste es eigentlich mal gegeben haben, weil wenn jetzt alles auseinanderfliegt und es wird immer kälter, dann muss irgendwann mal alles beisammen gewesen sein und es war heiß. Und das ist dann dieser Zeitpunkt des Urknalls, in dem halt alles auseinandergeflogen ist. Ist es jetzt sehr vermessen, jetzt schon zu diesem Zeitpunkt zu fragen, was bitte denn da kurz davor passiert ist?
Das ist ganz einfach zu beantworten. Es gibt keinen kurz davor. Sondern die Zeit hat erst da angefangen. Genauso wie da nicht...
Aber wo befand sich denn das alles?
Weil halt diese Zeit und der Raum dynamisch sind und sich...
Gab es einfach keine Zeit?
Ja, es gab keine Zeit. Es gab keine Zeit und es gab auch keinen anderen Raum. Es gab keinen außerhalb Raum, in dem sich das alles bewegt hat. Deswegen macht diese Frage zum Glück. Kann ich die dadurch zurückschicken, dass ich sage, das macht keinen Sinn? Die Zeit hat erst angefangen zu diesem Moment.
Trotzdem stellt man sich natürlich die Frage, wo befindet sich denn das alles? Ich meine, wenn sich das irgendwie ausdehnt, dann muss es ja auch irgendwo sein.
Nein, es ist aber überall. Wenn du von irgendeinem Ort im Universum einfach sozusagen rückwärts in der Zeit gehst, dann landest du da.
Okay, gut. Also es gibt diesen Ort, es war scheiße heiß.
Es war wirklich scheiße heiß.
Es gab da viel Materie, wo auch immer die hergekommen sein mag. Weil die muss ja immer auch mal irgendwo... Irgendeiner muss sich das ja mal ausgedacht haben. Also ich will jetzt hier nicht religiös rangehen, aber es ist irgendein Grund dafür, dass es muss ja gegeben haben. Aber das wollen wir jetzt erstmal weiter nicht verfolgen. Jetzt gucken wir einfach mal, was ist denn sozusagen passiert.
Genau. Also dazu liefert halt dieses scheiße Heiß den Schlüssel. Weil wie gesagt, heiß ist irgendwie hohe Energie. Und so ganz genau wissen wir das nicht. Also was bei wirklich Zeitpunkt Null passiert ist, weil wir halt irgendwie noch nicht unendlich hohe Temperaturen gesehen haben, sondern wir können im Prinzip da nur verlässliche Aussagen drüber machen für die Energien, wo wir eine Vorstellung haben, was da schon mal passiert ist. Und zum Beispiel gab es halt so einen Zeitpunkt, ungefähr 150.000 Jahre nachdem das alles angefangen hat. Da war es gerade so heiß, wie es jetzt an der Oberfläche der Sterne heiß ist. Das ist eine Temperatur von ein paar tausend Grad, die sich dadurch auskennzeichnet, dass da die Bewegung der Elektronen so schnell ist, dass sie nicht mehr verlässlich an die Atomkerne gebunden sind. Also da zittern sie so, dass sie mal dem Atomkern verloren gehen. Und das ist so ein Prozess wie Verdampfen. Also da verdampfen die Elektronen aus den Atomen raus.
Literally.
Und das sieht man ja auch, wenn man sich eben die Sonne anguckt. Da sieht das anders aus als, also das sieht halt aus wie eine massive Scheibe, die natürlich sehr hell ist. Aber das ist halt so heiß, weil dann jetzt einzelne Atomkerne rumfliegen und einzelne Elektronen, gibt es auf einmal geladene Teilchen. Vorher die Atome sind ja neutral, weil es sich gerade immer balanciert in der Ladung. Aber jetzt fliegen auf einmal freie, beladene Teilchen um. Das nennt man dann Plasma. Und weil geladene Teilchen eben auf elektromagnetische Kräfte reagieren, ist das dann für Licht und durchlässig. Ich kann ja auch nicht in die Sonne reingucken, sondern ich sehe halt nur die Oberfläche der Sonne. Weil dann die elektromagnetischen Wellen halt streuen an diesen freien Teilchen. An den freien geladenen Teilchen. Deswegen ist das das Ende, bis zu dem ich auch maximal mit elektromagnetischen Wellen im Universum zurückgucken kann. Weil davor wurde es undurchsichtig.
Ein einziges Plasma.
Ein einziges Plasma. Und weiter kann man nicht zurück. Man kann aber dieses Glühen, was sozusagen der Oberfläche der Sonne entspricht, das kann man schon noch sehen. Zwar nicht, indem man irgendwo mit dem Teleskop hinguckt, aber man kann das wahrnehmen, dass die Sache ist, dass diese Wärmestrahlung von diesem Plasma, die ist inzwischen natürlich auch abgekühlt. Weil es ist ja eine Zeit vergangen und es hat sich alles ausgedehnt. Und diese Wärmestrahlung, die halt ursprünglich zu dem Zeitpunkt ein paar tausend Grad heiß war, ist inzwischen durch die Ausdehnung und Abkühlung nur noch 2,7 Kelvin. Also 2,7 Grad über dem absoluten Nullpunkt.
Schon recht kalt.
Ist schon recht kalt. Ungefähr minus 270 Grad Celsius. Aber die kann man wahrnehmen. Also das sind halt Mikrowellen, das strahlte Mikrowellenbereich. Und die kann man messen. Wie denn? Entdeckt hat man das, indem man Radarmessungen auf der Erde gemacht hat. Und da hat man das als Rauschen gesehen. In den 60er Jahren.
Also Radarmessungen des Alts sozusagen.
Nee, das war keine astronomische Beobachtung. Sondern ursprünglich wollten sie transatlantische Kommunikation machen. Die hatten so einen großen Ballon mit Metallfarbe eingepinselt. Irgendwie 40 Meter Durchmesser, den haben sie hoch in die Atmosphäre geschickt. Und dann wollten sie irgendwie von Europa nach Amerika oder umgekehrt. Also da gab es halt noch keine Kommunikationssatelliten. Dann hatten sie die Idee, wir nehmen eine große Metallkugel, einen großen Ballon mit Metalloberfläche und da schicken wir Radarwellen dagegen. Und die werden dann reflektiert und dann in Amerika können wir die wieder auffangen. Da haben sie so Experimente gemacht. Muss man dann eine sehr empfindliche Antenne haben, weil der Ballon ist halt passiv und man sieht halt nur so ein bisschen die Reflektion. Dann haben sie eine sehr große, sehr empfindliche Mikrowellen-Antenne gebaut. Und die hat immer gerauscht. Allerdings ging das Rauschen nicht komplett raus, wie sie sich das erhofft hatten. Und dann haben sie festgestellt, das kommt von oben. Es kommt aus dem Himmel und es kommt im Großen und Ganzen aus der gleichen Richtung. Und das...
Also aus einer bestimmten Richtung?
Nein, aus allen Richtungen.
Aus allen Richtungen.
Und das ist halt diese Mikrowellen-Hintergrundstrahlung. Das haben sie dann schnell kapiert.
Ein kosmisches Grundrauschen.
Genau. Das ist das Nachglühen dieses Plasmas des Urknalls. Und dann daraufhin, also die haben auch einen Nobelpreis dafür gekriegt, daraufhin hat man dann Satelliten in die Erdumlaufbahn oder gar nicht mehr in die Erdumlaufbahn, sondern also ins All geschossen, die das dann genau vermessen haben und dann auch die Abhängigkeit davon von der Richtung vermessen haben. Also da gab es im Wesentlichen zwei große Satelliten, die das irgendwie bisher Pionierarbeit geleistet haben. Der erste hieß Coby. Der hat als erstes die Temperatur abhängig von der Richtung genau vermessen. Und dann ein weiterer, die Wilkinson Microwave Anisotropy Probe, WMAP. Die hat das sehr genau vermessen. Und daraus weiß man eigentlich, das liefert im Wesentlichen die Daten, die wir über die Kosmologie, also über den Ablauf von dieser Expansion und dem Universum auf diesen ganz großen Zeitskern haben. Die kennt man aus diesen Temperatur-Messungen. Man vermisst da die Temperatur.
Und welche Erkenntnisse kann man denn daraus gewinnen aus diesem Grundrauschen? Was liest es denn daran ablesen?
Daraus kann man zum Beispiel ablesen, was so die mittlere Materiedichte über das Universum gemittelt ist. Und da ist es ja zum Beispiel sehr wichtig, also wenn die Materiedichte zu groß ist, im Vergleich zu der Auseinanderflieggeschwindigkeit, dann ist die Gravitationskraft von all der Materie im Universum so groß, dass sie irgendwann diese Auseinanderflieggeschwindigkeit so abbremst, dass sich das irgendwie dann gebremst wird und wieder zusammenfällt. Oder wenn die Dichte zu klein ist, oder halt die Geschwindigkeit umgekehrt zu groß ist, dann gewinnt die Geschwindigkeit und es fliegt immer weiter auseinander und es wird immer leerer. Und die Beobachtung ist einfach, das ist verdammt genau balanciert, genau auf der Mitte dazwischen.
Das heißt, es fliegt zwar gerade alles auseinander.
Und es wird auch immer, also es wird nicht umkehren oder höchstens ganz, ganz spät. Aber es ist aber auch nicht mehr als das unbedingt zum Auseinanderfliegen nötig. Also das ist sehr genau balanciert, erstaunlich genau. Und außerdem weiß man aber auch, man kann, also das sieht man halt aus diesen, kann man aus diesen Mikrowellendaten zurückrechnen. Was man natürlich andererseits machen kann, ist man kann einfach die Sterne zählen. Weißt du, wie viele Sterne da stehen? Man guckt einfach, zählt wie viele Galaxien sehe ich so, wie dicht sind die gepackt? Und ich kann halt dadurch, und ich weiß halt, wie schwer typischerweise so ein Stern ist, und dann kann ich auch zählen. Und da sehe ich, das ist viel zu wenig. Also das ist nur 10 Prozent dieser kritischen Dichte.
Das heißt, es muss noch mehr geben, außer den Sternen?
Außer zumindest den leuchtenden Sternen. Ich sehe ja nur, was irgendwie Licht aussendet.
Wir haben ja noch den ganzen Planeten, ne?
Ja, aber das macht auch im Sonnensystem nur ein, also das macht nicht 90 Prozent der Masse aus. Also die nicht leuchtende Materie ist nicht so wirklich viel. Also es leuchtet schon ziemlich viel.
Woher will man denn das wissen, wenn man die nicht sehen kann?
Na ja, man hat ja so indirekte Hinweise. Erstens weiß ich ja, wie schwer die Erde ist, und dann kann ich auch gucken. Also diese nicht leuchtende Materie absorbiert ja auch Licht. Also und sie übt auch ein bisschen Gravitation. Also man hat da gewisse Vorstellungen, und es ist nicht so, dass irgendwie 10-mal so viel normale Materie durch die Gegend fliegt, wie die, die ich anhand ihres Leuchtens sehen kann. Und das ist diese sogenannte dunkle Materie.
Die ist aber, ist man sich da jetzt schon sicher, dass es die gibt, oder ist das jetzt erst mal nur so eine These?
Also wir wissen nicht, woraus die besteht. Was wir wissen, sie besteht nicht aus den gängigen Teilchen. Die besteht nicht aus normalen Atomkernen und Atomen. Oder irgendwelche kleinen dunklen Sterne, die nie gezündet haben oder so. Das ist es nicht, das wissen wir. Aber wir sehen sie halt, weil wir ihren gravitativen Effekt in dieser Mikrowellenstrahlung sehen können.
Das heißt, sie hat schon auch Masse?
Jaja, das ist das Einzige, was wir von ihr wissen.
Damit hat sie auch Energie, sozusagen.
Aber sie hat Masse. Da liegt irgendwo Masse rum, aber wir können sie nicht sehen.
Und die Masse ist eigentlich auch dieselbe Art Masse, wie man sie aus den anderen Teilchen sieht.
Man sieht halt die gravitative Wirkung, und da wirkt sie halt so. Und da gibt es noch einen anderen Hinweis drauf. Man kann gucken, wie Galaxien rotieren. Man kann insbesondere gucken, wie der äußere Teil von Galaxien mit welcher Geschwindigkeit er rotiert, im Vergleich zu dem inneren Teil von Galaxien. Und da kann ich auch daraus zurückrechnen, wie viel, wie sich denn die Materie über die Galaxie verteilt. Weil die gleicht ja mit ihrer Gravitation sozusagen die Zentrifogalkraft von der Rotationsgeschwindigkeit aus. Und wenn man das genau analysiert, sieht man auch, dass ziemlich genau der gleiche Faktor ein Zehntel ist, das, was man sieht, und es muss noch mehr geben.
Das heißt, auch wenn man jetzt mal nur die Milchstraße anschauen würde, die ja so schön plakativ so um uns herumgekranzt ist. Und das ist ja sozusagen eigentlich der Compound, den man am besten wahrnehmen kann.
Ja, man kann aber so schlecht von draußen drauf gucken. Insofern, ich glaube, man macht das mit anderen Galaxien.
Okay, gut, dann lieber mit anderen Galaxien. Aber das ist ja an dir auch bewusst. Aber wenn man sich das sozusagen so vorstellt, also es muss außer den ganzen Sonnen und außer den Planeten muss da noch irgendwas anderes sein. Aber da fällt mir aber ein, dass wir eigentlich bei der Feststellung, dass das ist Zustand, dass wir eine Sache ausgelassen haben, nämlich gerade jetzt sozusagen diese Galaxienbildung, die im Prinzip nochmal so wie die Planeten um die Sonne kreisen, auch die ganzen Sonnen um, was denn eigentlich?
Umeinander im Wesentlichen. Also die rocken sich zusammen und...
Es gibt da keine dunkle Materie, sondern in der Mitte, die dann irgendwie das auch nochmal alles zusammenhält?
Naja, es wird schon alles irgendwie potenziell in die Mitte gezogen. Deswegen sind die Galaxien in der Mitte dichter. Also da ist es nicht so weit von Stern zu Stern im Mittel.
Ah, okay.
Und es ist auch so, dass sich in den meisten Galaxien hat sich inzwischen auch so viel Materie angesammelt, dass sich da auch so ein schwarzes Loch gebildet hat. Und zwar ein großes schwarzes Loch. Auch man weiß von der...
Nicht bei allen.
Aber schon wohl bei den meisten. Also die Idee ist auch, dass eventuell erst sich dieses schwarze Loch gebildet hat, dass erst so viel Materie zusammengefallen ist, dass sich ein schwarzes Loch bildet und dann sozusagen, dass das auch mit ein Keim war für das Ganze.
Dass es sozusagen sich die ganzen Sonnensysteme einfängt und damit die Galaxienbildung überhaupt erst betrieben wird.
So wie so ein Kondensationskeim. Also da weiß ich nicht genau, aber diese schwarzen Löcher sind so schwer wie ungefähr eine Million Sonnenmassen.
Und da ist normale Materie drin. Und die können wir aber auch nicht sehen, weil es sind ja schwarze Löcher.
Genau, wir sehen nichts. Aber es gibt einen coolen Film im Internet. Ich weiß nicht, ob der bei YouTube ist, aber ich suche den nach ein noch mal raus. Das ist einfach, da sind astronomische Bilder, die über die letzten Jahrzehnte vom Zentrum der Mähstraße gemacht worden sind, mit super Zeitraffer zu einem Film zusammengeschnitten. Und da sieht man die Sterne um etwas, also man sieht die Bewegung der Sterne, die da in der Nähe sind. Und die bewegen sich offensichtlich um etwas rum, aber da ist nichts.
Den Link findet ihr dann in den Show-Notes zu diesem tollen Film. Also bewegt sich was, aber da ist nichts.
Genau, also man sieht nichts, um was da die Anziehung aussieht.
Aber da ist was.
Na ja, sonst würde da keine Anziehung sein. Also die Sachen fliegen, man sieht richtig diese Ellipsenbarn.
Ja, aber wenn das so ein schwarzes Loch ist, wo das Licht nicht mehr raus kann, dann ist das ja einfach normale Materie, so herkömmlich, so wie wir sie kennen. Bloß wir können sie nicht sehen, weil das Licht da nicht rauskommt. Ist das nicht die Erklärung für diese fehlenden 90% Energiemasse?
Nee, das funktioniert nicht. Weil wir eben diese Rotationsgeschwindigkeiten messen und wir sehen, dass diese dunkle Materie relativ gleichmäßig über die Galaxie verteilt ist. Die kann nicht nur im Zentrum sitzen. Das heißt überall. Ja, also die häuft sich schon bei den Galaxien. Aber es ist sogar so, dass die Galaxien ja meistens Scheiben sind. Aber diese dunkle Materie ist eher so verteilt, dass diese Kugel vermisst. Also die geht aus der Scheiben-Ebene auch raus. Das deutet darauf hin, dass diese Teilchen, aus denen die dunkle Materie besteht, nicht sehr stark wechselwirken. Also die werden nicht außer Gravitation, nicht weiter angezogen von den anderen Sachen. Sonst würden sie quasi auch auf Dauer in die Scheibe reinfallen. Sondern die fliegen einfach so selber auf großen Ellipsenbahnen.
Um die Galaxies auch herum. Also sie sind schon auch Opfer dieser Gravitation?
Ja, natürlich.
Und sie reagieren sozusagen auch auf eine Masse, die sie selbst eigentlich gar nicht sind.
Nein, aber Gravitation ist universell. Also alles, was selber Gravitation ausübt, kann es auch eben anhand von einem Gefallen sein.
Ja, kann auch sein, dass man da mit irgendeinem neuen Masse, ich meine, wenn man nicht weiß, was es ist, kann es ja auch irgendwas sein, was sich jenseits der Gravitation bewegt. Und dann, was weiß ich, sich einen Scheißdreck interessiert für diese Galaxien.
Naja, aber alles, was wir sehen, ist der gravitative Effekt davon.
Okay, also den gibt es schon.
Ja, das ist das Einzige, woher wir wissen, dass das gibt. Weil wir sehen, da muss irgendwas sein, was noch Gravitation ausübt.
Okay, ausübt und natürlich dann auch selber Opfer davon ist. Das heißt, die ist irgendwie schon auch an unsere Galaxie und damit auch an unser Sonnensystem angedockt. Ich kann davon ausgehen, dass jetzt in diesem Raum befindet sich irgendwie nicht nur 1000 kg Material, sondern unter Umständen auch noch 5000 kg dunkle Materie, die wir nicht sehen, nicht anfassen, nicht beweisen können.
Nee, die ist dünner verteilt.
Aber es ist welche hier.
Ja, also wir wissen nicht genau, wie...
Moment.
Also es kann halt sein, dass das als einzelnen Teilchen besteht, die dunkle Materie, die relativ schwer sind. Also im Mittel, glaube ich, in der Milchstraße ist es ungefähr ein Proton pro Kubikmeter. Das heißt, dass du irgendwie 1000 kg in diesem Zimmer versammelt hast, ist sehr außergewöhnlich.
Ah, okay, also eher so im Milliardstilgramm-Bereich, wenn überhaupt.
Weniger, so ein Zehnhoch. Also ein Proton wiegt irgendwas mit Zehnhoch minus 27 Kilo und das halt pro Kubikmeter. Also das ist so die Masse und davon halt zehnmal so viel. Und das heißt, wenn das Teilchen selber zehnmal so schwer ist wie ein Proton, hast du eins im Mittel pro Kubikmeter. Weil wenn es halt noch mal schwerer ist, wird es halt dünner. Und das halt auch gemittelt über das Ganze. Also es kann halt sein, dass sich in diesem Moment in diesem Zimmer gerade kein einziges von diesen Teilchen findet.
Ist dunkle Materie anwesend? Wir wissen es nicht. Okay, gut. Das heißt, die liegt jetzt irgendwie überall rum. Und man weiß eigentlich nur, dass es sie gibt und dass sie irgendwie in Wechselwirkung mit dem, was wir so kennen, steht.
Aber nur gravitativ.
Genau, aber wir wissen nicht, was oder vielleicht nur gravitativ. Kann ja sein, dass es ja auch noch andere Auswirkungen auf uns hat.
Ja, aber keine, die wir sehen. Also sonst würden wir halt, also man sucht ja nach der. Und das sind hauptsächlich so Sachen, dass man versucht, die irgendwie an irgendwas zu streuen. Also man nimmt irgendwie, diese Experimente sind typischerweise sowas, ich nehme einen großen Tank voll Wasser, also so Swimmingpool-Größe. Und hoffe, dass ein Teilchen mit so dunkler Materie irgendwie zufällig ein Teilchen aus dem Wasser, irgendwie so ein Proton aus dem Wasser oder so trifft. Und dann, wie eine Billardkugel stößt, und dann sehe ich halt das Proton durch das Wasser fliegen. Das kann man sehen, wenn ein einzelnes Proton durch Wasser fliegt, wenn man nur genau genug hinguckt. Und das, man nimmt halt so einen Swimmingpool, macht es dunkel, und dann wartet man.
Oh man.
So gibt es viele Experimente, die nach solchen Sachen suchen.
Verstehe.
Und hier haben wir ein bisschen nichts gefunden.
Okay. Und was ist so deine Einschätzung? Also ich meine, wie wird das so sein, wir und die dunkle Materie? Kann sein, dass wir ewig aneinander vorbeilaufen.
Kann sein. Aber eine andere Sache, die man machen kann, ist zu versuchen, sie zu erzeugen. Also nicht nur darauf warten, dass sie zufällig vorbeikommt, sondern sie zu erzeugen. Und das macht man halt typischerweise in Teilchenbeschleunigern. Und das ist eine der Sachen, die man da zu erzeugen hofft. Und da gibt es so Kandidaten. Also wir haben halt so Ideen, was es so alles an Teilchen geben könnte. Und da gibt es auch Ideen darüber über Teilchen, die man noch nicht gesehen hat. Aber einige davon, also das Stichwort da ist Supersymmetrie, wären natürliche Kandidaten für solche Teilchen.
Supersymmetrie.
Das ist in der Konsequenz die Idee, dass es, also wir haben ja irgendwie schon über Elektronen geredet und über Atomkerne. Und die Atomkerne bestehen ja selber nochmal irgendwie aus Protonen und Neutronen. Die bestehen wiederum noch mal aus kleineren Teilchen, nämlich den Quarks. Aber, und die sind dann aber irgendwie Elementarteilchen. Und die Elektronen auch. Und dazu gehört auch noch das Lichtteilchen, das Photon, oder das ist ein Gamma-Quant, wenn man irgendwie so eine Radioaktivitätssprache machen will. Das sind alles Teilchen, die nach heutigen Stand nicht nochmal selber aus kleineren Dingen bestehen, nach allem, was wir wissen. Die sind auch wirklich punktförmig.
Okay, und Teilchen heißt jetzt wirklich, das ist sozusagen das, was wirklich Masse ist.
Ja, außer, dass Energie auch Masse ist. Das Teilchen ist ein Ding, was punktartig ist, und das kann Eigenschaften haben, das kann geladen sein. Das hat eine Masse, also die meisten Teilchen haben Masse, und kann auch noch so ein paar andere Eigenschaften haben.
Das kann geladen sein mit Energie.
Ne, mit elektrisch geladen. So, dass das, wenn ich ein elektrisches Feld habe, dass sich das irgendwie...
Und wenn es zittert, dann hat das irgendwie Energie.
Ja, aber da das keine Substruktur hat, kann es nicht in sich zittern.
Sondern nur relativ zittern.
Und es kann noch magnetisch sein. Und es kann noch so ein paar Eigenschaften haben. So und nun alle diese Teilchen. Die Geeksymmetrie sagt, das ist nur die halbe Miete. Es gibt zu jedem Teilchen noch ein anderes Teilchen. Also zu jedem Teilchen-Typ gibt es noch ein Partnerteilchen. Und das ist in ganz vielen Eigenschaften ähnlich. Es hat die gleiche Ladung, es hat sozusagen die gleiche magnetische Geschichte. Es hat etwas einen Drehimpuls. Das weitreichende Drehimpuls ist, die Eigenschaft zu rotieren, um sich selbst, obwohl das auch ein Bild nur ist, weil das nicht ausgedehnt ist. Wenn es ein Punkt ist, kann es nicht um sich selbst rotieren. Aber es hat so Eigenschaften als würde es um sich selbst. Also es verhält sich wie ein kleiner Kreisel letztendlich. Da ist es ein bisschen anders. Und sonst sind im Wesentlichen die Eigenschaften gleich. Aber von denen hat noch keiner was gesehen.
Ist das dann diese dunkle Materie?
Und da ist die Idee, dass von diesen Partnerteilchen das leichteste möglicherweise die dunkle Materie ausmacht.
Aber woher weiß man denn, dass es diese Partnerteilchen gibt, wenn man sie noch nie gesehen hat?
Also das ist schon eine Spekulation. Aber auf die wird man auf verschiedenen Wegen gebracht. Aber einer der Wege, die man beschreiten kann, ist wenn man, jetzt machen wir Elementarteilchen-Versiegelung und reden über Teilchen-Kollisionen, wenn man die ausrechnet, also man macht einerseits Exprimente, aber den will man natürlich auch theoretisch irgendwie ausrechnen können, wie was, wenn ich zwei Elektronen mit der Energie von 100 Gigaelektronenvolt so und so kollidieren lasse, was ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das und das Teilchen im Winkel von 36 Grad wegfliegt, sowas will ich ja ausrechnen können. Das ist ja das, was ich messe in so einem Teilchenbeschleuniger. Und das will ich auch ausrechnen können. Und das können wir relativ gut, aber da gibt es so Rechentricks. Wenn ich da naiv rechne, kommt er immer irgendwie unendlich raus. Und da gibt es aber Tricks, von dem unendlich, ein unendlich abzuziehen und 42 rauszukriegen. Also vielleicht nicht 42, sondern 1 durch 137 ist so eine andere Zahl, die man da vielleicht besser rauskriegt als 42. Aber das läuft unter dem Namen Renommierung. Und dieses Abziehen von unendlich minus unendlich funktioniert wesentlich besser, wenn ich auch noch diese Partnerteilchen habe. Und da kann ich jetzt noch ein Bild machen, was das vielleicht ein bisschen deutlicher macht. Also jetzt reden wir auch irgendwie über Quantenphysik, wo irgendwie alles vibriert und Teilchen aus dem Nichts entstehen können und so. Und was passieren kann, es kann spontan, einen Stichwort haben wir noch gar nicht geredet, Antimaterie.
Moment, jetzt muss ich mal kurz wieder mal dazwischen gehen. Weil wir haben jetzt doch einen sehr, sehr großen Bogen umspannt, hängt natürlich irgendwie wie alles zusammen. Also wir hatten irgendwie das Universum und wir sind uns jetzt, glaube ich, so ein bisschen sicher, woraus es im Wesentlichen besteht. Es war halt irgendwann mal ganz heiß und es ist irgendwie auseinandergeflogen und es ist im Wesentlichen immer noch dabei, das zu tun. Und es tut es irgendwie nicht schneller als es muss, aber es tut es irgendwie gerade so, dass es halt auch weiterhin sich ausdehnt. Und vielleicht fängt es sich irgendwann selbst nochmal ein und fällt auch wieder in sich zusammen. Das ist irgendwie unklar.
Aber nicht nächste Woche.
Aber nicht nächste Woche und das ist auch erstmal nichts, worüber man groß diskutieren muss. Wesentlichen fliegt derzeit alles auseinander und das wird auch noch eine ganze Weile lang das tun. So und in diesem ganzen System haben wir irgendwie Sonnen mit ihren Planetchen, irgendwie Agglomerationen, die Galaxis und überhaupt. Und man kann sich überhaupt dieses ganze sich ausdehende Gewäsch von Masse irgendwie anschauen. Und man kann dadurch, dass man eben dieses Grundrauschen auch noch analysiert und sich das Ganze anschaut, einen ganz guten Bild davon machen, wie viel Masse da insgesamt rumfliegt. Man stellt auch fest, es gibt definitiv noch mehr Masse und zwar sehr viel mehr Masse als die, die wir bisher so konkret verortet haben in Form von Sonnen und den wahrscheinlich dazugehörenden Planeten. So was das aber jetzt genau ist, weiß man nicht. Das Ganze richtet dann sowieso dann wiederum den Blick vom Großen aufs Kleine, nämlich die Frage, woraus besteht denn das irgendwie alles? Und dann waren schon irgendwie die Griechen dabei mit ihren Atomen und ganzen chemischen Experimente herausgefunden, okay, alles klar, alles besteht immer wieder aus irgendwelchen kleineren Teilchen, irgendwo ist das Schluss. Da war das Atom von vornherein schon mal die Hoffnung, dass es dann nicht sehr viel weitergeht. Aber dann hat man da auch nochmal mit dem Hammer draufgeschlagen und festgestellt, aha, aha, da gibt es irgendwie Protonen und dann gibt es irgendwie Neutronen und dann gibt es irgendwie Elektronen, die da rumfliegen. Dann hat man auch eine Weile gedacht, das wäre es jetzt irgendwie aber auch gewesen. Und dann hat man noch einen größeren Hammer ausgepackt und festgestellt, auch diese Dinge bestehen wiederum aus kleineren Teilen. Jetzt kommen wir sozusagen ins Allerkleinste, was ja dann irgendwie auch so ein bisschen die Hoffnung ist, dass wenn man das irgendwie alles soweit auseinanderklamm büttert, dass man dann auch die Antwort bekommt auf das ganz Große. Auf das ganz Große und vor allem auch, was es irgendwie mit dieser dunklen Materie auf sich hat. Und jetzt ist sozusagen die Frage, was ist da der Stand der Dinge? Jetzt war es ein bisschen verwirrend mit irgendwie, wie viele Teilchen es da jetzt irgendwie gibt. Vielleicht sollten wir das noch mal ein bisschen sanfter aufdröseln, so von dem Atom nach unten, weiß ich nicht mal, so mit den Quanten und Quarks und so weiter. Also klar, Atom ist ein Kern, da fliegen die Elektronen drum herum. Der Kern besteht irgendwie aus Protonen, die sind irgendwie ganz schwer, die machen im Wesentlichen die Masse aus und dann kleben da irgendwie noch so Neutronen irgendwie so als Heißkleber da irgendwie so mit dran.
Nein, also das ist was anderes.
Dann ist das ein Tutor mal einfach.
Also vielleicht sollten wir, da gibt es halt verschiedene Spekulative gerade. Vielleicht sollen wir erstmal das reden, was gesichert ist.
Genau, das ist sehr gut.
Das ist das sogenannte Standard-Modell der Elementarteilchen. Und diese Neutronen, die sind im Prinzip genauso wie Protonen. Also die sind ungefähr genauso schwer, also bis auf sehr wenigen Unterschieden. Und die haben aber keine, die Protonen sind elektrisch geladen, die Neutronen nicht. Aber sonst, also bis auf, im Wesentlichen der Unterschied zwischen Protonen und Neutronen, ist nur ihre Ladung. Aber sonst sind die genauso gleich. Die bilden den Atomkern zusammen. Die machen, die zusammen machen die Masse des Atomkerns aus.
Aber rein von der räumlichen Ausdehnung her, sehr klein.
Ja, 10 minus 15 Meter ist da so die Hausnummer. So, nun kann man in verschiedenen Richtungen weitergehen. Erst, also wir haben irgendwie die Elektronen und wir haben die Protonen. Nun stellt man, in welche Richtung gehen wir weiter. Vielleicht sollten wir erstmal den Kern auseinander packen. Die Protonen, haben wir gesehen, sind elektrisch positiv geladen. Nun ist es ja so, dass gleiche Ladung sich abstoßen. Also die Elektronen werden durch die elektromagnetische Kraft auf ihrer Bahn gehalten, weil der positive Kern und die negativen Elektronen ziehen sich an. Aber die Protonen würden sich untereinander abstoßen. Die haben also eigentlich dicht beieinander nicht viel verloren. Also es muss irgendwas anderes geben, was diesen Kern zusammenhält. Und deswegen gibt es eine weitere Kraft. Also wir haben bisher Gravitation und Elektromagnetismus. Und damit die Atomkerne zusammenkleben bleiben können, auch dass die Neutronen überhaupt da bleiben, wo die überhaupt keine elektrische Ladung haben, gibt es eine weitere Kraft, die erst mal nur auf diese Neutronen und Protonen wirkt. Das ist die sogenannte starke Kernkraft. Da hat man keinen so tollen Namen mehr gefunden. Er ist einfach The Strong Force. So mit Luke und... So, das hält den Atomkern zusammen. Und dann weiß man außerdem noch, gibt es noch eine andere, die heißt die Starke Kraft, weil es auch noch eine schwache Kraft gibt. The Weak Force. Die sorgt dafür, dass manchmal das eben noch auseinanderfallen kann. Die ist letztendlich verantwortlich für den radioaktiven Wetterzerfall. Und das sind alle Kräfte, die es unserer Meinung nach gibt im Universum. Gravitation, Elektromagnetismus und die starke und die schwache Kernkraft. Die erklären alle Kräfte, die wir im Universum sehen. Wenn du auf deinem Stuhl sitzen bleibst und nicht da durchfällst, ist das im Wesentlichen die elektromagnetische Kraft. Der Umstand, dass du nicht nach oben wegfliegst, ist die Gravitation. Und dass die Protonen, aus denen du bestehst, zusammen in den Atomkern bleiben.
Dass man Stuhl hält, ist sozusagen die starke Kernkraft.
Nee, dass der Stuhl hält, ist die elektromagnetische Kraft. Aber...
Ernsthaft? Ach so, weil die...
Elektronen, also die Ausdehnung des Stuhls wird im Wesentlichen durch die Elektronen bestimmt. Und die Elektronen werden elektromagnetisch auf jeden Fall. So, jetzt haben wir das eine sortiert. Wir haben die Kräfte sortiert. Und deswegen können wir auch sagen, wir sind so sicher, weil alles, was wir jemals gesehen haben, wird durch diese vier Kräfte beschrieben. Und wenn halt jemand kommt und sagt, er kann irgendwie mit der Wünschelroute was messen, dann widerspricht das einfach fundamental dieser Feststellung, dass wir nur vier Kräfte haben. Deswegen kann man da von vornherein sehr skeptisch sein. Also, weil wir haben sehr komplizierte Exponente gemacht und alle haben nur irgendwie vier Kräfte und keine Psi-Force oder...
Ich habe noch nicht so ganz verstanden, was diese Weak Force jetzt macht. Von wem geht die aus? Auch bei der starken Kernkraft ist ja die Frage von... Ich meine, wenn die Protonen da gehalten werden, ich meine, wer strahlt die aus?
Also, ich sollte vielleicht noch mal genauer beschreiben, was die Weak Force macht. Es gibt nämlich die Möglichkeit, dass radioaktiv ein Neutron, wenn ich ein freies, ein Neutron ohne Kern habe, ich kann einzelne Neutronen haben, die zerfallen radioaktiv, die werden im Wesentlichen ein Proton, ja, wir haben gesehen, Neutronen und Protonen sind fast das gleiche, die Neutronen sind ein ganz bisschen schwerer.
Was heißt denn überhaupt radioaktiv zerfallen? Das haben wir jetzt die ganze Zeit irgendwie vorausgesetzt, verpufft einfach.
Nein, da entstehen andere Teilchen draus. Das Neutron verwandelt sich in einen Proton und außerdem fliegt noch ein Elektron weg. Das kann ich schon daher sehen, da die elektrische Ladung insgesamt gleich bleiben muss. Neutron hat keine elektrische Ladung, Proton hat plus eins, Elektron hat minus eins.
Das heißt, ein Neutron ist eigentlich so ein Proton und ein Elektron in einem.
Ja.
Oder zumindest kann es dahin überführt werden.
Außer, dass es noch nicht ganz der Wahrheit letzter Schluss ist. Denn wenn man das genau angeguckt hat, hat man gesehen, das kommt nicht ganz hin. Das passt so mit den Stoßgesetzen, wie man sie vom Billard-Spielen kennt, nicht ganz auseinander. Wenn ich nur diesen Zerfall angucke und gucke, mit welcher Geschwindigkeit das Proton und welcher Geschwindigkeit das Elektron wegfliegt, das geht nicht ganz auf. Der Impuls, also Geschwindigkeit mal Masse, summiert über alle Teilchen, muss vorher und hinterher gleich sein. Das sind die Gesetze, die einem sagen, wie die Billard-Kugeln wegfliegen, wenn sie kollidieren. Und das geht nicht ganz auf. Da fehlt irgendwas. Und deswegen wusste man da schon, da wird noch ein Teilchen erzeugt, das sogenannte Neutrino. Das fliegt auch noch weg, aber das ist wieder Unsicht. Das sieht man nicht, weil es wieder elektrisch nicht geladen ist und außerdem sehr viel weniger Masse hat.
Aber das hat man auch in dem Sinne nicht beobachtet?
Das hat man inzwischen beobachtet, aber damals, als man nur gesehen hat, dass da was fehlt.
Es müsste einfach eins geben, und man hat gesagt, okay, wahrscheinlich geht da eins weg.
Genau. Das hat man aber in einem dieser Swimming-Pool-Experimente. Also inzwischen kann man die machen. Da kann man das Neutrino nachweisen. Und dann stimmt auch alles. Das gibt es also auch. Es gibt noch dieses Neutrino. Das ist im Prinzip auch ein Cousin von dem Elektron. Das ist eher so ein Teilchen wie das Elektron. Nur ist es halt der arme ungeladene Cousin von dem Elektron. Er hat keine elektrische Ladung, und deswegen fällt es nicht so auf wie das Elektron.
Was macht so ein Neutrino dann, wenn es da irgendwie so...
Das fliegt weg.
Und dann dockt sich das irgendwann wieder irgendwo an, oder...
Nee, das ist sogar so, dass es halt eigentlich... Das spürt nur diese schwache Kahnkraft, und die ist schon sehr schwach. Und deswegen dockt das typischerweise erstmal lange nicht irgendwo an. Weil das fliegt einfach so. Und dieser Prozess läuft auch übrigens in der Sonne ab, wenn die ihre Energie erzeugt. Und deswegen erzeugt die Sonne in jedem Moment auch ganz, ganz viele Neutrinos. Und die fliegen auch durch uns durch. Und von denen sind ganz viele in diesem Zimmer. Und wir merken es nicht. Weil die durch uns.
Einfach durch uns durchgehen. Die sind so neutral, wie man sich das nur vorstellen kann.
Ja. Ganz selten stoßen sie mal, aber das ist...
Aber das ist auch irgendwie keine Erklärung. Dunkle Materie oder so.
Nein, also das weiß man, die können das nicht ausmachen. Das hat man auch mal gedacht, aber das passt nicht.
Okay, aber sehen tut man die auch nicht, in dem Sinne. Also man sieht sie in dem Swimmingpool. Aber wenn man jetzt ins Weltall schauen würde, würde man sie ja jetzt so nicht sehen.
Nein.
Aber da fliegen wahrscheinlich eine ganze Menge davon rum.
Aber die machen nicht viel Masse aus.
Okay, weil das halt einfach nur diese kleinen Punktteilchen sind.
Genau. Also das sind noch Freunde von dem Elektron. So, und das Proton...
Wir sind jetzt immer noch beim radioaktiven Zerfall.
Ja, genau.
Und zerfallen tun nur diese Neutronen.
Genau.
Die Protonen zerfallen nicht.
Das kann auch sein. Es kann auch der umgekehrte Prozess stattfinden. Das ist der sogenannte Inverse-Better-Zerfall. Da passiert genau das Umgekehrte. Da zerfällt ein Proton in einen Neutron. Und es werden jeweils die Antiteilchen, jetzt kommt die Antimaterie ins Spiel, von dem Elektron und dem Neutrino ausgesandt.
Das ist auch alles Theorie, oder befinden wir uns jetzt für dich noch im gesicherten Bereich?
Ja, das ist absolut felsenfest. Das sind die Positronen. Bekannt aus der Positron-Elektronentomographie. Wenn du beim Fußballspielen deinen Knie ruinierst, wirst du in eine dieser vielen Röhren, die jetzt in Krankenhäusern rumstehen. Bei dem PET, da werden radioaktive Zerfälle, wo eben diese Positronen erzeugt werden. So was, was so zerfällt, wird dir ins Knie injiziert. Und das kann man dann auffangen.
Dann strahlt mein Knie sozusagen.
Genau. Und diese Positronen, also das sind die Antimaterie-Elektronen, die sind genauso wie das Elektron, bloß die sind positiv geladen. Aber die haben die gleiche Masse, die haben auch eine positive Masse und die unterliegen der gleichen Gravitation. Und die sind absolut gesichert. Die wetzeugen wir jeden Tag in großer Zahl.
Okay. So, das heißt, bei dem Versuch jetzt aufzuklambüsern, was eigentlich in unserem Atonkern irgendwie drinsteckt, wir haben die Protonen, wir haben die Neutronen, aber schon der radioaktive Zerfall, der permanent sowieso irgendwie stattfindet, zeigt uns, da ist noch mehr drin. Das ist sozusagen die nächste Ebene von Bestandteilen. Und das Neutron hat irgendwie in sich einen Proton und einen Elektron, was dann...
Nee, das ist einfach das Gleiche.
Also eine andere Form...
Genau.
Ah, okay, gut, verstehe.
Das steckt nicht da drin.
Okay, das ist ja auch interessant. Das ist sozusagen eine Form, die es sich wählt, und es ist möglich, dass es diese Form auch ändert und sich anders ausprägt, was im Prinzip dafür spricht, dass das in sich nochmal... Genau, dass es aber auch in sich nochmal aus ganz anderen Komponenten zusammengebaut ist, und dass das, wie wir es wahrnehmen als Proton, sozusagen nur eine Darstellungsform dieser Gesamtmengelage ist.
Das hat erstmal nicht... Also ob das Substruktur hat oder nicht, ist unabhängig davon. Also es zerfallen auch Dinge, die keine Substruktur haben. Wir haben vorhin über diese Myonen geredet, die aus der Höhenstrahlung kommen und die halt so langsam zerfallen, weil sie so schnell sich bewegen. Die haben nach allem, was wir wissen, keine Substruktur. Das sind einfach Myonen, aber die zerfallen auch eben radioaktiv. Und da entsteht im Wesentlichen, die wandeln sich in den Elektron um und da fliegen auch noch zwei Neutrinos raus, damit andere Summen wieder aufgehen. Aber das ist aber der gleiche schwache Zerfall. Das ist auch die schwache Wechselwirkung, die dafür zuständig ist.
Diese schwache Kraft haben wir ja noch nicht so richtig gefasst.
Also wir haben im Wesentlichen schon alles, was man über sie sagen kann, gesagt.
Dann fassen wir das nochmal kurz zusammen. Also die starke Kernkraft hält den Kern zusammen.
Die schwache Kraft sorgt dafür, dass gewisse Teilchen sich ineinander umwandeln können.
Das heißt, das ist die Idee.
Also die macht im Wesentlichen die Umwandlung zwischen dem Neutron und dem Proton unter so ein bisschen ferner liefen anderes Zeug. Und die macht auch die Umwandlung zwischen dem Myon und dem Elektron.
Das ist sozusagen so eine Kraft des Wandels. Eine Kraft, die irgendwie Teilchen in einen anderen Zustand überführt.
Genau. Wenn das gerade energetisch opportun ist.
Aber jetzt gibt es trotzdem noch andere Teilchen, die da irgendwie noch drinstecken.
Aber das ist erstmal der Atomkern. Nun kann man die Sachen genau untersuchen, indem man sie auseinander schießt und kollidiert. Und dann stellt man fest, das Proton hat eben eine Ausdehnung. Das Elektron ist wirklich punktförmig, aber das Proton hat eine Ausdehnung von den schon erwähnten 10-15 Metern. Ein Femtometer. Und wenn man da Sachen Elektronen zum Beispiel da draufschießt und versucht das aufzulösen, dann sieht man, da schwirrt einiges in so einem Proton durch die Gegend. Was zusammengebunden ist und dieses Proton ausmacht. Nämlich die sogenannten Quarks. Na, man schießt Elektronen auf Proton und guckt, wie die rausfliegen. Wie die Richtungverteilung... Wie die abprallen. Wie die abprallen. Die prallen nicht an der Oberfläche ab, sondern die gehen irgendwie durch. Außerdem fliegt anderes Zeug raus. Da werden Sachen erzeugt. Wenn ich Energie zusammenbringe, dann kann ich Teilchen erzeugen. Wenn ich das genau analysiere, sehe ich erstens, die haben eine Ausdehnung. Zweitens verhält sich diese Streuung, die Statistik dieser Streuevents, so, als ob das nicht ein Teilchen ist oder eine homogene Verteilung von Zeug, sondern als ob da einzelne Teilchen noch drin rumfliegen.
Das sieht man.
Und das sind die Quarks?
Das sind die Quarks. Und derer sind erst mal drei.
Pro was?
Pro Proton oder Neutron.
Das heißt, das ist wirklich die Substruktur?
Das ist die Substruktur.
Man geht davon aus, dass ein Proton tatsächlich aus drei Quarks besteht. Drei identische Quarks oder sind das unterschiedliche Quarks?
Also erstens die Zahl drei, auf die kommen wir noch. Das ist leider auch noch mal komplizierter. Und dann ist es noch so, also es sind auch unterschiedliche. Und außerdem hat man in so Kollisionsexperimenten festgestellt, dass genauso wie es zu dem Elektron gibt es auch noch Myonen, gibt es zu Protonen und Neutronen auch noch mal einen ganzen Arsch voll Andere, die auch so vom Prinzip her so ähnlich sind, die sind ähnlich groß, haben ähnliche Ladung, aber verhalten sich anders, sind schwerer. Und da gibt es einen ganzen sogenannten Teilchenzoo. Da hat man in den 60er-Jahren und 70er-Jahren Experimente gemacht und irgendwie jedes Jahr hat man so ein neues Ding gefunden. Und das Name Überhand, das war nicht mehr schön. Also man will ja möglichst einfache Dinge haben und wenn man irgendwie jedes Jahr ein neues Teilchen findet, dann...
War das frustrierend.
Ist das zumindest für Leute, die alles möglichst einfach haben wollen, muss man halt sagen, vielleicht liegt dem ja noch was zugrunde.
Also man hat sozusagen, ich meine, ich frage mich die ganze Zeit, wie man sozusagen auf dieser Miniatur-Ebene überhaupt noch da zwischen unterschiedlichen Teilchen unterscheiden kann.
Man hat ja diese Detektoren. Also diese Kollisionen lässt man ja stattfinden irgendwo, wo man das auch verfolgen kann, was da rausfliegt. Und sozusagen der einfachste Prototypen-Teilchendetektor ist zum Beispiel ein Geigerzähler. Der misst, wenn da ein radioaktives Teilchen durchfliegt. Was der genau gesagt misst, ist, dass da ein geladenes Teilchen durchfliegt. Der misst nämlich die Ladung, die da durchfliegt. Und das ist im Wesentlichen ein Draht. Ich brauch vielleicht nicht erklären, wie ein Geigerzähler funktioniert. Aber irgendwie weiß der das. Der weiß das.
Geigerzähler weiß alles.
Und der Trick ist, so eine Art Teilchendetektoren sind im Prinzip, dass man lauter ganz kleine Geigerzähler nebeneinander baut. Und dann sieht man, wenn da ein geladenes Teilchen durchgeflogen ist. Und dann guckt man halt, welche der Geigerzähler nacheinander anschlagen. Und dann sieht man, wo das lang geflogen ist. Und dann sehe ich erstmal die Bahn von dem Teilchen. Nun kann ich noch den Trick machen, dass ich in das ganze Ding ein Magnetfeld drum rum, also das in ein Magnetfeld tue. Und geladene Teilchen bewegen sich auf gekrümmten Bahnen im Magnetfeld. Und die Krümmung der Bahn hängt davon ab, wie schnell das Teilchen da durchfliegt, also konkret von dem Impuls. Also wenn ich die Bahn vermesse und sehe, was der Radius von der Bahn ist, weiß ich, wie viel Impuls da hat. Und außerdem kann ich auch die Masse, die Energie von dem Teilchen sehen, im Wesentlichen hängt, wie lange das Teilchen braucht, um da gestoppt zu werden, weil das ja irgendwie streut mit allem Möglichen. Dadurch kann ich Energie und Impuls von dem Teilchen messen und daraus kann ich die Masse ausrechnen. Also so kann ich die Masse von den Elementarteilchen bestellen.
Und daran macht man den Unterschied fest. Das heißt, man sieht, es ist ein anderes Teilchen, weil es hat einfach eine andere Masse. Einfach unterschiedlich groß Unterschied.
Und außerdem kann ich halt gucken, in was für andere Teilchen die zerfallen. Also dieser ganze Teilchen so zerfällt in andere Teilchen radioaktiv. Und dann kann ich halt gucken, wer in was zerfällt. Und dann stelle ich fest, da gibt es halt noch so Ladungen. Also die elektrische Ladung, aber nicht in dem Sinne, dass da irgendwas von angezogen wird, sondern das einfach, ich weiß, dass bei jedem Prozess muss die Summe der elektrischen Ladung vorher gleich sein mit der Summe der elektrischen Ladung hinterher. Das heißt, es kann nie ein Proton in ein Elektron zerfallen, weil das nicht aufgeht von der elektrischen Ladung. Und da kann ich eben noch andere solche Ladung, also der Umstand, dass gewisse Teilchen nicht in andere zerfallen, kann ich mir dadurch zusammenreimen, dass ich sage, da gibt es noch eine weitere Ladung, die halt dann, die unterschiedlich bei den beiden Teilchen ist, sodass die nicht ineinander zerfallen können. Da gibt es halt so einen minimalen Satz, wie viele solche Ladung ich annehmen muss, damit alle Prozesse, die sonst, wo ich denken könnte, dass sie vielleicht stattfinden, dann nicht mehr stattfinden. Und diese Ladung unterscheidet dann auch die verschiedenen Teilchen.
Also es ist durchaus beherrschte Technologie, und man stellt einfach fest, es gibt diese Teilchen viele. Die haben dann alle irgendwie noch einen schicken Namen und so.
Die heißen typischerweise noch irgendwelche Buchstaben einfach. Also die ersten hießen dann noch, irgendwie hatten noch tolle Namen, und dann irgendwann hat man sie noch mal buchstabenbenannt, und irgendwann hat man sogar nur noch gesagt D2271, weil das war irgendwie ihre Masse.
Alle waren total frustriert, wahrscheinlich als wir anfingen, dann so, oh, wir haben ein neues Teilchen entdeckt, wir werden den Nobelpreis kriegen, und dann so, oh, ich hab auch eins, und dann immer mehr, immer mehr, und dann so, oh, ist das langweilig. Und so eine Diversität kann eigentlich nur bedeuten, dass man da einfach noch tiefer reinschauen muss.
Das ist genauso wie die Chemie, also wo ich sehe auch irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, so ungefähr 100 verschiedene chemische Elemente, und die erkläre ich halt dadurch, dass ich sage, die bestehen alle aus Protonen, Neutronen, Elektronen, halt aus einem Atom, und die unterscheiden sich nur dadurch, wie viele Protonen und Elektronen zusammenkommen. Wenn ich halt einen Proton habe und einen Elektron, dann nenne ich es Wasserstoff. Und wenn ich irgendwie zwei Protonen, zwei Neutronen und zwei Elektronen habe, dann nenne ich Helium und so weiter. Und ich kann dieses ganze chemische Periodensystem zusammenfassen, indem ich sage, ja, es gibt da, ja, es gibt halt irgendwie Plus- und Minus-Teilchen, und um die Masse aufzufüllen, gibt es noch die Neutronen. Und so ein dem zugrunde liegendes Prinzip sucht man auch für diesen ganzen Teilchen zu. Und in dem Fall sind das die Quarks. Also das war die Idee danach zu suchen.
Das war dann aber auch erstmal eine These.
Genau, aber...
Wir befinden uns immer noch in dem gilt-als-gesichert-Bereich.
Wir befinden uns in dem absolut gilt-als-gesichert-Bereich, hat Nobelpreise für gegeben.
Okay, wer ist da drauf gekommen mit den Quarks?
Da waren verschiedene Leute beteiligt. Der Name, den man auf jeden Fall nennen muss, ist Murray Galman. Der hat auch so populärwissenschaftliche Bücher geschrieben, der Jaguar und irgendwas oder so. Der ist alt, der ist über 80, hat so ein Institut in Santa Fe, wo er auch über ganz tolle Dinge und Chaos und Emergenz, also so, wo hier Business-Lieder auch eingeladen werden. Ist aber ein lustiger Typ. Aber ein sehr schräger Vogel, der hat den Namen Quark auch erfunden. Das geht auf einen James-Joyce-Zitat zurück. Da ist ja auch ein Quell, also dass das irgendwie, also für lesendere Leute ist ja Joyce so ein bisschen so, Douglas Adams für lesende Leute. Die heißen halt nicht Zaffa Bibelbrocks, sondern die heißen Quarks. Aber da gehören noch andere Leute dazu, auch Herr Fritsch aus München, das muss ich jetzt sagen, weil ich aus München komme, hat da auch irgendwie Claims to Fame in dem Geschäft. Also verschiedene Leute, Quarks, derer gibt es sechs verschiedene. Mit sechs verschiedenen Quarks kann man diesen ganzen Teilchen zuklären.
Aber was ist denn sozusagen die eigentliche Qualität dieser Quarks, sodass man nicht sagt, ihr seid jetzt auch nur Teilchen, sondern ihr seid das, was die Teilchen zusammensetzen?
Naja, mit denen kann ich alle diesen ganzen Teilchen zu erklären.
Ja, wie denn? Also ich meine, was...
Und zwar muss ich immer für diese proton-neutronenartigen Teilchen, die sogenannten Nukleonen, da brauche ich immer drei. Und die Quarks haben auch wieder seltsame Namen.
Aber Elektronen besteht auch aus Quarks?
Nein, das Elektron ist elementar. Wenn ich Elektronen aufeinanderschieße, dann verhalten die sich so, als ob sie punktartig wären. Und da gibt es ja auch, da gibt es, also es gibt noch dieses Myon, das hatten wir schon. Und dann gibt es noch eins, das heißt Tau, aber dann Schluss.
Elektron, Myon, Tau.
Und jeder von denen hat noch ein Neutrino. Aber das ist Schluss. Das sind die sogenannten Leptonen. Die bilden eine Sorte. Und das ist Schluss. Und dann gibt es den ganzen Zoo. Das sind alles Sachen, die aus Quarks bestehen. Die sind im Prinzip wie die Protonen Neutron.
Das heißt, diese Leptonen und die Quarks, das sind sozusagen die Building Blocks des nächsten Levels.
Genau. Und nach allem, was wir wissen, oder nach dem gesicherten Wissen, sind das auch Final Building Blocks.
Das heißt, die bestehen nicht selbst auch noch mal wieder.
Nein, da ist die Geschichte vorbei. Zumindest, was die gesicherte Erkenntnis angeht.
Gut.
Und derer gibt es halt sechs. Und die Quarks haben komische Namen. Die kommen auch in Paaren. Up und Down heißt das erste Paar. Das zweite Paar heißt Strange und Charm. Und das letzte Paar heißt Bottom und Top.
Das klingt ja so ein bisschen nach einer Gay-Party. Was geht denn da? Also, ich meine, was sind denn dann so die Eigenschaften?
Also, das ist im Prinzip, spiegelt das das Bild bei den Leptonen wieder. Also, bei den Leptonen gibt es jetzt drei Familien. Elektronen, Myonen und Taufamilie. Jeweils mit zweien. Nämlich dem Teilchen und dem zugehörigen Neutrino. Und das wird gespiegelt auf dieser Quark-Seite. Die kommen halt auch in Pärchen, wie halt diese Namen, die halt in ein Pärchen kommen, ab und down. Strange und Charm sind nicht so ein Pärchen, aber das ist es.
Das heißt, es gibt zwei große Gruppen, in denen es drei Ausprägungen gibt, die dann wiederum in so Pärchen daherkommen.
Ganz genau. Das ist aber, dann haben wir es geschafft.
Das ist ja schon mal zu wissen.
Das sind alle sechs. Zwei mal sechs und...
Strange und Charm?
Also das kommt daher, dass man das Strange, also die werden noch immer schwerer in der Reihenfolge, wie ich sie genannt habe. Also Proton und Neutron bestehen nur aus Up und Down. Proton besteht aus zwei Up und einem Down. Und Neutron besteht aus zwei Down und einem Up. Die Pneumonik davon ist, dass man den letzten Buchstaben von Up und Down angucken muss. Das sind P und N. Und das ist wie bei Proton und Neutron. Und da, wo das passt, sind es zwei und beim anderen eins.
Diese Wissenschaftler.
Also mit denen macht man die gewöhnliche Materie. Und dann gibt es halt diese schwereren, wie halt das Myon auch schwerer ist als das Elektron. Das sind Strange und Charme. Das ist die nächste Familie. Und als man angefangen hat, die zu erzeugen, hat man als erstes halt auch dieses Strange. Also Dinge erzeugten, in denen so ein Strange drin war. Und diese Strangeness ist eine von diesen Ladungen, von denen ich geredet habe. Da hat man erst gesehen, da gibt es halt irgendwas, was sonst nicht so direkt ineinander zerfällt. Und das muss halt auch zählen. Das ist die sogenannte Strangeness gewesen. Und später hat man ja festgestellt, wie Strangeness einfach nur die Zahl der Strange Quarks, die da drin ist.
Das heißt, Ladung, es gibt nicht nur eine Ladung, sondern es gibt so verschiedene Arten von Ladung.
Es gibt die elektrische Ladung. Es gibt eine elektrische Ladung und dann gibt es halt noch andere. Also die heißen allgemeine Quantenzahlen, aber...
Jetzt kommen wir, glaube ich, auch für dich müssen zu weit.
Ja, also das sind einfach nur Zielgeschichten. So, und die Strangeness war halt eine dieser Eigenschaften, die man brauchte, um zu erklären, warum gewisse Teiche nicht in andere zerfallen können. Und das lag einfach daran, dass da ein Strange Quark drin war.
Das heißt, mit dieser Teilchenbeobachtung, mit den Magneten und irgendwie den abgelenkten Bann, wo man dann irgendwie sehen kann, wie schnell sie sind, wie viele Masse sie haben und so weiter, hat man diesen ganzen Teilchen so aufgemacht und dann irgendwann die Theorie aufgestellt, okay, alles klar, da gibt es irgendwie noch Building Blocks und wir nennen das jetzt mal irgendwie Quarks. Und bei den Elektronen hat man dann auch noch die Leptone. Das war dann wahrscheinlich auch im gleichen Schritt, oder?
Ja, ungefähr, der Zeit, glaube ich.
Okay, gut so. Und damit bringt man die ja dann sozusagen überhaupt auch erstmal wieder viel mehr im Kontext. Weil vorher waren die irgendwie total unterschiedlich und jetzt basieren sie eigentlich auf ähnlichen Grundstrukturen.
Genau. Aber die Quarks unterscheiden sich von den Leptonen dadurch, dass die starke Kernkraft auf sie wirkt. Die Leptone spüren die nicht. Und die Quarks spüren die. Und zwar ziemlich stark, da heilt der Name stark. Und die wird... Und nun ist es auch immer noch in diesem Geschäft so, dass man sich auch so vorstellen kann, dass diese Kräfte dadurch wirken, dass irgendwelche Kraft-Übermittler-Teilchen ausgetauscht werden. Die gibt es nämlich auch noch. Das eine haben wir schon kennengelernt. Das Teilchen für die elektromagnetische Kraft, das ist das Photon. Das ist einfach das Lichtteilchen. Das Licht ist sozusagen nur die elektromagnetische Kraft, die zwischen zwei eingeladene Teilchen... ausgetauscht wird. Und die Teilchen für die starke Kraft, das sind die sogenannten Gluonen. Also der schwachen Kraft, das sind also Bosonen.
Ah, das heißt, diese Leptonen-Quarks-Geschichte, also das, woraus der, das Atom besteht, und wo man sich auch relativ sicher ist, das ist sozusagen alles, das sind so Fermionen, das sind sozusagen die Dinge, die sind einfach, die sind?
Die machen Materie, also man kann sagen, die stellen die Materie da, und das andere stellen die Kräfte. So ganz grob gesprochen.
Genau, grob gesprochen. Und Kräfte, wissen wir mal, gibt's irgendwie vier, es gibt die starke Kraft, da ist das passende Boson dann dieses Gluon. Das heißt, das ist sozusagen das, wodurch diese Kraft auch real transportiert wird. Das ist irgendwie das, was die Quarks irgendwie zusammenhält und das ist irgendwie so stark, dass da irgendwie nichts gegen angeht. Dann gibt's elektromagnetische Kraft. Das ist das Photon. Das Photon ist sozusagen das Teilchen, hin und her geschickt wird.
Und das äußert sich als Elektromagnetismus. Was sich als Elektromagnetismus äußert, ist der Umstand, dass der Photonen hin und her geschickt werden.
Und diese Geschwindigkeit, in dem ein Photon von einem wo marschiert denn das überhaupt lang?
Von einem geladenen Teilchen zu einem anderen.
Von einem geladenen Teilchen zu dem anderen. Und da bleibt es dann kurz und dann marschiert das selber wieder weiter oder ist das mehr so ein Billard-Kugel-Effekt?
Ne, die können frei erzeugt werden. Die werden dann einfach geschluckt. Das wird einfach von dem einen erzeugt und das andere schluckt das dann.
Okay, aber die sind sozusagen Ausdruck dieser Kraft.
Genau. Und das ist in dem Sinne Ausdruck dieser Kraft, als wenn wir uns beide jetzt auf Inline-Skates gegenüberstehen würden und ich habe einen Ziegelstein in der Hand und den werfe ich dir zu. Dann rolle ich ein bisschen nach hinten und wenn du ihn aufgefangen hast, rollst du auch ein bisschen nach hinten. Und dann könnte man auch sagen, zwischen uns hat eine abstoßende Kraft gewirkt, aber was wir nur gemacht haben, ist ein Ziegelstein hin und her zu werfen.
Diese Photonen sind sozusagen diese Ziegelsteine? Genau. Beziehungsweise auch die Gluonen auch, also alle Bosonen sozusagen. Da haben wir ja jetzt auch sozusagen noch diese schwache Kraft für die...
Für die heißen die Teilchen W und Z-Bosonen.
Aha. Und die hat man aber auch schon mal gefunden.
Die hat man an dem Vorgänger vom RHC in Zan genau vermessen.
Das heißt, jetzt bleibt jetzt noch die Kraft für die Gravitation oder was? Das ist keine richtige...
Ja, die heißen Gravitonen, aber die ist vermutlich zu schwach, um dass man sie wirklich im Teilchenbeschleuniger sehen kann.
Okay, aber dieses Higgs-Boson, das hat damit alles nichts zu tun?
Das ist nicht direkt ein Kraftteilchen. Deswegen habe ich so ein bisschen gezögert, als ich gesagt diese Einteilung zwischen Materie und Kraftteilchen gemacht habe. Aber es hat eine Eigenschaft, nämlich ein Boson zu sein, die auch diese Kraftteilchen haben. Aber es ist nicht direkt ein Kraftteilchen.
Also es geht jetzt sozusagen nicht um die Kraft der Gravitation, die zu finden, sondern nochmal was anderes. Und was macht dieses Higgs-Boson jetzt so interessant? Einfach nur, weil man es noch nicht gesehen hat.
Genau. Und ohne das ist das Modell, was wir haben, inkonsistent.
Wer ist denn denn wir?
Also sagen wir mal die orthodoxe Mehrheit der Mainstream. Also das Standardmodell, was allgemein akzeptiert ist, da gehört dieses Higgs-Teilchen noch dazu.
Okay. Und wenn man das nicht findet, dann hat man es irgendwie nicht bewiesen.
Nee, schlimmer noch, dann stimmt es nicht. Also es gibt so Leute, die irgendwie wetten laufen haben, ob das gefunden wird. Und eigentlich ist es die pessimistische Sicht, dass es gefunden wird. Weil dann wird einfach das bestätigt, was man erwartet hat. Und wenn es nicht gefunden wird, dann weiß man, dass es es nicht gibt. Und dann weiß man, dass es irgendwie was grundsätzlich falsch ist mit dem, was man sich bisher so ausgedacht hat. Und das wäre eigentlich das viel interessantere Ergebnis.
Weil sonst hätte man ja jetzt die Wahrheit.
Dann muss man halt von vorne anfangen und neu den Bleistift spitzen. Und dann hoffen wir natürlich auch, dass wir diese supersymmetrischen Partnerteilchen finden. Das ist aber nicht so sicher wie das Higgs. Und sonst weiß man halt nicht, was einen erwartet, wenn man in den See sticht.
Hängt denn das jetzt alles mit dieser String-Theorie zusammen, mit der du arbeitest, oder ist das dann nochmal ein komplett neues Feld?
Das ist nochmal ein neues Feld. Da geht es dann, da ist die Idee, dass diese Teilchen doch nicht elementar sind, sondern selber aus vibrierenden Seiten bestehen. Aber dann gibt es halt nicht mehr 6 und 6 und nochmal 4 und nochmal ein Higgs, sondern dann gibt es nur noch Seite und die kann irgendwie schwingen in verschiedenen Zuständen. Also das würde dann nochmal alles zusammenbauen. Plus die Gravitation, die wir halt bisher irgendwie außen vor gelassen haben in diesem Elementar-Teilchengeschäft.
Gibt es ja jetzt überhaupt noch irgendeinen Bereich, in dem man sich sozusagen unsicher ist. Ich meine jetzt dieses Higgs-Boson, weiß jetzt nicht, schwer nachzuvollziehen, was das jetzt alles so für Auswirkungen hätte, wenn man es findet oder nicht findet. Aber im Prinzip, man hat jetzt ein relativ stabiles Modell. Und nicht wahr, woraus irgendwie alles besteht und welche Antworten das hat. Aber es gibt ja auch noch Fragezeichen. Ich meine, das mit der dunklen Materie ist irgendwie...
Genau, das hätte ich jetzt auch gesagt. Das ist eins der großen Fragezeichen.
Das ist komplett irgendwie unklar.
Und eben, wie wirklich die Gravitation an das Ganze angedockt wird, das ist das eigentlich Konzept.
Also eigentlich diese Krümmung sozusagen.
Wie die zusammenpasst mit diesem ganzen Teilchenzeug. Und der Quantentheorie. Also dieses Krümmungskonzept passt erst mal fundamental nicht in dieses Quanten mit Fluktuationen und so. Das muss zusammengebaut werden.
Aber rein aus der Beobachtung, der Erfahrung, weiß man, dass es schon irgendwie alles da ist.
Also dass Gravitation da ist, das habe ich jeden Tag.
Ja, das stimmt. Mühsam.
Und das ist halt noch offen. Ja, und dann weiß man halt nicht, was man noch findet. Und dann gibt es noch so interne Konsistenzgeschichten. Viele Leute finden dieses Standardmodell der Elementarteilchen auch nicht besonders ästhetisch. Also du hast ja auch schon so geguckt, als ich gesagt habe, dann gibt es noch ein Teilchen, und dann gibt es noch ein Teilchen, und hier nochmal irgendwie nochmal sechs, und dann nochmal Quarks.
Und das soll die Wahrheit sein?
Das sollte die letzte Antwort sein. Das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein. Und da kann man halt auch nochmal gucken, ob es da vielleicht doch noch irgendwie ein Thema gibt, unter dem man das alles einfacher subsummieren kann. Also es bleibt auf jeden Fall noch eine ganze Menge zum Vorschlag.
Trotzdem, was klar geworden ist, weil jetzt haben wir eine echt lange Sendung, was ganz gut klar geworden ist, ist einfach erstmal, das Kleinste und das Größte in diesem Universum hängt extrem nah miteinander zusammen. Man kann davon ausgehen, dass es irgendwann mal so einen Start gegeben hat und wir befinden uns irgendwie noch mitten im Flug. Und wir sind zwar dem Verstehen der kleinsten Teilchen sehr nahe gekommen, aber so richtig diese Weltformel, die irgendwie alle Fragen zusammenbringt, insbesondere eben das Problem der Gravitation, ist so noch nicht gefunden?
Nein, oder zumindest noch nicht, dass man sicher sein kann. Wir glauben halt, einen Kandidaten zu haben.
Mit der String-Theorie.
Das ist dann, wo dann nochmal sieben Dimensionen dazukommen, oder waren es elf? Ich weiß gar nicht.
Insgesamt elf. Vier haben wir, sehen wir ja schon.
Und dann, ach so, sozusagen nochmal sieben extra. Ja. Ist, glaube ich, nochmal ein eigener Themenkreis. Ein eigenes Fass für Chaosradio Express. Und ich sage, machen wir jetzt hier den Deckel drauf.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, ich habe zu danken. Eine riesen Flug. Lange Sendung. Ich glaube, das war jetzt einfach auch mal die längste.
Was ist das schon gegen 14 Milliarden Jahre?
14 Milliarden Jahre, das stimmt. Oder waren es Billionen?
Billionen habe ich vorhin behauptet. Schreiben wir noch ins Blog.
14.000 Milliarden Jahre. Auf jeden Fall eine verdammt lange Zeit. Solange wird es nicht dauern, bis hier die nächste Sendung rauskommt. Und ja, ich hoffe, das hat jetzt hier irgendwie schöne viele Fragen aufgestellt. Die könnt ihr dann auch wieder hineinwerfen. Ihr wisst schon, in das Blog, blog.chaosradio.cde, denkt mal, Robert wird auch ein bisschen mitlesen und auch noch ein paar Pointer liefern. Wenn ihr selber da in die Tiefe gehen wollt, dann müsst ihr wohl theoretische Physik studieren.
Ja.
Wäre zumindest schon mal ein Kandidat. Habt ihr denn dann genug Nachwuchs?
Wir können immer noch gute Leute gebrauchen. Also, brecht euer Informatikstudium ab.
Genau, das ist eh alles zunächst wert. Gut, dann sage ich jetzt nochmal Danke. Und tschüss allen Hörern. Bis bald bei einer nächsten Ausgabe von Chaosradio Express.